what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the
pregame all right before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way you
are going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in and
also guys get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today yes all of the
world's problems started when we gave
women the right to vote so I say take it
away get t-shirt in the description we
have shipped this week so if you have
your t-shirt on take a selfie and tweet
it at me #i deem also guys um how many
likes to open up the chat today
King 1,500 okay 1,500 likes and we will
open up the chat otherwise make sure you
join our monthly membership subscription
and how many over how many super chats
are we reading today 25 okay so if you
have a question comment or concern
please please send a super chat over $25
we will read be nice guys be nice it's
very awkward for me when you're not so
anyways um so today so do um name age
relationship status and a fun fact
starting here go around and then second
row um my name is Kelly lck I am
Timeless um I love
DIY and what's the last thing um fun
fact a fun fact that's the DIY that was
my fun fact do do relation ship status
oh I'm super single and
celibate go ahead I'm Ria I am
34 and I am single uh fun fact my first
language is Dutch oh wow that's fun I'm
sharion I'm 37 I'm single and really I
am very spiritual like I will not walk
over
crack
is that superstitious
superstitious superstitious interesting
W what you said spiritual what
what I didn't realize I didn't realize
the bar for spiritualism was not
walking go
ahead I'm Mara um I'm
33 my relationship status is
private and interesting fact is I have a
song out now who Return to Sender by
newer with my sister me stream it with
sister Mel are you guys are wait are you
guys twins sisters okay but yeah I was
like you guys look exactly like wow much
PR much like twis but yeah that's the
interesting fact of stream that Return
to Sender new
Nua okay go ahead um I'm tan I'm
37 um I'm in a
relationship um what else is it name AG
relationship status and fun fact um fun
fact is I write scripts and I'm I do
I've got a I'm a radio host and a
podcast host and events coordinator all
right awesome hi I'm Jaa I'm 30 I'm a
super single and fun fact I'm a singer
producer product manager who is an
advocate of purple purple yeah why
purple why not blue um to be honest I
first dyed my hair purple I know it's
black now but we'll get into that L but
um purple at the bottom I know but this
is like I'm having like an identity
crisis because there's so much black
here but anyways I only dyed my hair
because I was like oh my God I'm 18 now
and then it just stuck forever and now
everything has to be purple okay it's
nice I like purple go ahead hi I'm Mel
I'm
32 um I'm single fun fact is uh my
sister and I had a sty IST and creative
directors for all of our videos our
music
videos scre scre goad my name is Allah
and I am 33 years old I am in a
relationship and um fun fact I have a
podcast called the real happy hour
podcast where I revie films and TV shows
also have a radio show called um Vibe
Central oh cool thank you hi I'm Miss
Ling I am 32 fun fact I am a singer
songwriter hairdresser Barber educ
and um I once picked up 50 Cent from the
airport jeez oh is that when you was a
taxi driver
when no darling are you guys are you
guys my was the chur and I was the
assistant when you say picked up do you
mean like I literally met him at the
gate and said hello hi I'm may come with
me well tell him you know a show here
you know what I mean next time this
years
ago yeah go ahead uh Troy Francis I'm 49
years old old I am incredibly single and
uh I'm a dating coach and content
creator and a fun fact about me is I'm
still a bit jet lagged because I was
just in Miami Mexico City bogatar
Columbia and then New York city so I got
I got back the other day so you know no
one's going to book you why cuz you're
single and you're no no I get criticism
I get no no no that's a good point I get
criticism from both sides because you'll
get criticism from people saying oh well
Troy hasn't got a girlfriend so
therefore he doesn't know what he's
talking about and then when you do have
a girlfriend people are say oh he
doesn't know what he's talking about cuz
he's not in the is he's not dealing with
with those women cuz he's already like
married off so either way either way
you're going to get haters you know what
I'm saying hairdress and her hair looks
a hot mess but what what if what in cat
to people who don't want a relationship
they just want to have a bit of the old
um but you said dating Cod well yeah
dating but that covers a multitude of
there's no end game then there's no end
game does that have to be you know
what's the end game for any of us well
yeah to to be fair if you look at the
numbers the future's Bleak for everybody
yeah yeah most of us will die alone
anyways anyways so speaking of that so
today's topic um we I wanted to talk
about so I saw this study right um that
talked about what percent of women do
you think get to be Housewives don't
Don't cheat and
look what percent do you think I'm going
to say 60 60% yeah I'm going say 30 30%
okay what what do you mean specify
Housewives as in married or they get to
stay home with their children oh oh can
I change it yeah yeah go ahead 30 30% 50
50% of women 40 I said 40 okay go
ahead 35 okay 35 40 okay 38 38
27 so the question is how what percent
of women want want to be
housewives that means their man can
afford for them to be a housewife maybe
30% 30% i' say 22 22% Troy 20% it's not
1% so I hate to burst your bubble
everybody 99.2% of women in the UK in
the UK Oh I thought we were like
including you know
Africa no no this is this is West
Western stats said UK I definitely would
have said so whatever I thought to
myself and I guess we'd have to you know
agree on this first I would say that the
best position to be in as a woman is to
be married to someone that you want to
be with the rest of your life and able
to stay home with the kids if if you so
want to would you agree if you so want
to yeah okay so let's bring if you want
to yes yeah so this is um so it kind of
question I it brought me to the question
who qualifies to be a housewife
like if you were going to apply for a
job that's say like the men only 10% of
men get a housewife they take a
housewife and they basically say ladies
ladies ladies here here's the
application what should it say on it so
I have a PowerPoint here um do you
deserve to be a housewife so wait and
then um number two go to the second
slide I thought it would be fun to put
what you guys think house W like what
you think you should bring to the table
in order to be a housewife um being able
to
sew are be doing one each one each one
each okay you that's a very nice
oldfashioned cuz back in the day there
was you couldn't like buy clothes so
your wife had to be able to make clothes
I just want to try this show of hands
who can sew sew yeah all right all right
you you can like you can really sew your
own clothes yeah I make my own clothes
customize I'm actually impressed okay go
ahead
a housewife you've already
failed what do you mean just be human
what what would you mean human okay okay
okay so so women women women are human
women are human but only 10% get to do
it so there's something special about
those 10% right it's got to be something
different about them they get it um okay
so this is going to be very
controversial how many meals okay go
so I'd
say and don't crucify me for this but
I'm going to say be a fe actual be a
female Fales you mean be a female female
you mean an anatomically anatomically
you mean it's cisgendered woman excuse
me but why would anyone crucify you I
would think I would think we said we
said we said housewife not house husband
so all right all right what about you I
would say to be a good housewife wife
you'd have to be very good in bed to
keep your husband all right so good at
sex good at
sex I think good with routine and
structure so if they're doing like a
hard 9 to5 whatever when they come back
they know they've got all the clothes
are clean they've got the meals nice
massage structure cloth structure
structure all right clothes meals
massage basically structure you're
taking everyone's alter with one
sorry she's she she did well in school
she's an
overachiever go ahead I would say to be
very suppored
supporting supportive okay supportive
I'm putting them in the Google Doc just
you know go ahead I would say mine is to
like be caring like I don't know if you
actually need to be the one doing all
the sewing cooking cleaning and
massaging but you need to care that
somebody's is taking care of it
okay that's actually good
the okay wait let me get this
straight 10% of women qualify for this
and they don't need to cook or clean
they just need to care not necess yeah
not necessarily like if there is
somebody who can cook and clean you need
to make sure they're doing it to the
standard that makes everyone in the
house happy right okay so so they manage
the cookers and the cleaners you make
sure it's done okay okay go ahead yeah
um be their peace
good one that's a very good one what
does that mean like can I can I have
some specifics cuz I hear this a lot but
I never know what it means yeah um so he
comes home and I say I am
peace that's
me you meditate together no unnecessary
headache
um just when they come home they want a
place to relax everyone wants a place to
relax and uh Retreat so
um yeah a lot of women Where Have You
Been what time did you call this
unnecessarily okay so not you can't
argue no arguing well you can argue but
within reason
unon there's a lot of gray area in that
though I know but I'm super chill you
come home yeah I'm two more children
should be I would just think the piece
is no arguing
right not nagging no nagging not nag
yeah no nagging okay what do you think
um a loyal woman deserves to be a
housewife it's all you got to be loyal
yeah you have to
Dam I was definitely almost the
housewife until just
now okay what do you think H patience
you need patience so much for the damn
kids you got about three kids I've been
I've been waiting for someone to say
give him kids oh you don't have to do
that you need be patient okay you wait
who said
you don't have to I don't think you have
to do that to be a
housewife you don't have to give them
kids yeah not not everyone wants not
every man wants kids you can still be a
housewife okay do men
typically I got I got production cutting
me up yeah I think was like I want
to remember remember remember you might
already have kids this is only 10% of
women get this so this is cream of the
crop the best of the best right so I I
would think they would give you kids you
know I thought we just said who who
qualifies not who's like the best one
well the best one ones qualify I mean
50% of them end up not having the job at
the end of the day right yeah because
they're not the best cuz none of us they
still they still qualified to initially
no no if you qual no if you qualify for
things you get them so if you don't get
it then you don't qualify not
necessarily but if 9% of women are
becoming housewives in the UK and 50% of
marriages fail then half of those women
didn't quite do a good job right yeah no
what about well I would say I would say
they didn't qualify for the housewife
role so there are men that can afford
Housewives there's just a very small
percentage of them you know prices are
going up you know most people need two
incomes so you know only 10% of women
could
qualify I think a a big proportion a big
part of that percentage is women that
turn a blind eye to a lot of things yes
that's yeah quite right
yeah yeah yeah a lot of them they take
we need to take all the advice from him
he knows he's like quite right can I can
can that be my answer turn a blind eye
if they turn a blind ey they turn a
blind ey to a lot of stuff then they're
ideal to be a housewife um I think the
other thing that I was going to mention
is uh they've got to not put themselves
into positions where they could
potentially be unfaithful in any sort of
way and that probably includes social
media so not friends loyal not not no
friends but not hoing yourself out on
social media and all that kind of stuff
respectful wa what is hoing yourself at
on social media well I mean trapping
wait I got it I got it no no selfies
yeah um well what about Justin Bieber's
what about Justin Bieber's wife you
would she's a model what's happened well
I mean Pearl often brings her up as an
example because if you look at her
pictures on social media she's married
to Justin Bieber but she's showing a you
know there's a lot of Flesh on display
there is that appropriate married to
Jay-Z do you think Jay-Z can say you
can't wear that she's Beyonce she's
twerking on I mean Beyonce Beyonce took
him screwing another chick so I think he
[Applause]
could I think they both make a lot of
money off of it but I'm saying like I
think if if he told her to do something
she'd probably listen if if she's
accepting if she's accepting cheating
you don't think he could tell her
something no he I don't think so not not
when it comes to her art and her
performance is her art like she's an
artist and he had to accept her that way
and so did Justin Bieber have to accept
he's one as a well she's not quite on
the level of be what her
name model her own lane she's and she
makes money from that yeah yeah but it'd
be better off but isn't it in an Ideal
World though just if we take the
celebrities out of it isn't it better
for the average dude you know you're
married to this woman and she's all over
social media she's got bikini shots and
all that you know like IAA like 20 you
know 20 2021 or whatever isn't it
wouldn't it be preferable not to have
that because he's kind
like advice I'm GNA go I'm going to go
even further so I I think a lot of times
in our culture we always use examples of
celebrities right but they're actually
not the real high value men typically
it's a very small percentage of them if
you look at high value men um they're
typically Executives lawyers doctors
that sort of thing and those men are not
wife enough up social media [__] not
not typically I does anyone disagree
with
that uh no the
thing none of my friends are married to
doctors no a lot of my friends are
doctors and you know I've got like a
variety of friends and they would they
they keep their private life private
they would not be going out with anyone
that's on social media so that's the
typical people they are or they keep
their like very very private they're
just lowkey hes because why are they
high value they're just off the radar
that's all like what makes them high
value what the guys
yeah what DOD is a low is a low keyho no
no no but I think I think to be honest
with you I would rather be with someone
that's not on social media so that you
haven't got to worry
about yeah because you are on a soci
yeah but that's the point is those guys
aren't TP like the the highest value men
are not typically big on social media
like I'm saying we use celebrities often
as an example but even celebrities the
guys that own the celebrities and are
the people behind the scenes that W make
way more money are not typically super
public and celebrities a lot of
celebrities like Jay-Z blah blah blah
they're not really high value man
because they're like ex Road man do you
know what I
mean also Troy I feel like if you're
secure as a human being in yourself and
you're secure in your relationship those
things are schematic she shouldn't
really care about things like that well
I I knew someone would bring out that
argument say if you were a real man you
would have mind said man I just said
secure I didn't I do I do get it no
Kelly I do I do get it I don't I don't
entirely disagree because look I mean if
I date a girl and she's on social like I
don't really care it's not a big deal
all I'm saying is in this specific
example we're talking about here if
we're talking about you're actually
going to marry somebody and she's
actually going to be in that 10% I think
a lot of dudes would be like you know
what I prefer it if she wasn't on social
Med Media or if it was very lowkey but
why because it's just kind of like why
do why does anybody go on social media I
mean it maybe to make money or it's to
get attention like why do most women
really bus
business okay so women women suck at
business yeah women I'm sorry even only
women can't even sell their butt for
$5.99 I swear they make like 500 bucks a
month tops look at theage look at
the
yeah I I would work I'm saying like most
most women don't run successful
businesses oh well I disagree with that
well the numbers do not I mean even I'm
I'm saying let's take only fans that's
the easiest sell like wouldn't you agree
sex to a guy that is the easiest thing
to sell I think about show my
feet like you don't have to do sex on
early fans you can actually do other
things but but the highest the highest
earning people and only fans are managed
by men though yeah I really I'm not up
for put
in for
ten let me let me find it it's the only
average only okay what do how much do
you think the average only fans model
makes a month the
average five grand five grand okay five
500 500 what do you think that's not
worth it what do you think uh I think
around about 10,000 what do you think
what's average though that 2,000 the the
average the average only fans model what
do you think she
makes I was talking about a corn model
just average ones that ain't someone
that's doing corn no it's only fans no
is she doing corn on there no not I
think the ones that ain't so popular you
just want to say cor okay who said who
said 200b Me 2 2000 2,000 I'm around two
2001 180 mon yeah think about how many
are getting like 2020 a month they did
one thing someone sent them 20 what do
you think it has to be higher
average off working in McDonald's
average I I made like I think I made
like 50 Quid on Tik Tok in like half an
hour so I was just like spreading your
toes no I I was just singing and and you
know you interact with people and people
send you gifts yeah yeah but are you
doing that on only fans without having a
a platform behind you to begin with I
think you just got to interact with the
right people okay what do you think how
much um I would like to go with for two
2,000 minimum 2,000 what do you think
500 okay um I said 5K hopefully no 500
why you getting your clothes off 50b
I a about how many
ofal and this is my case and this is my
case for why women are bad at business
because I look at and I'll tell you I'm
going to give you case number two why
most women are bad at business I'm going
to say most there are exceptions right
but you know then we also look at the
top earning women and they got all their
money from men um it's typically divorce
or or it's
typically they get their money from
their sexuality like Kim Kardashian so
yeah I think they're pretty bad
typically is that a bad business though
does that make us bad bad at business
because we sell our best like resource I
would say it takes significantly more
skill to sell a product rather than your
Bund I suppose it depends how you Le I
suppose it depends how you leverage it
afterwards right I mean if you use that
as the platform and then you leverage it
into something else afterwards but I
mean how many women have done that can
you think of examples got use what you
got to get
em Emily rowski is I think is trying to
transition to something else isn't she
but I'm not sure will she be successful
at that when she's not when she hits the
wall they're not they're not they're not
making money like that you can it's as a
content creator you can like tell who's
actually making money like none of these
chicks are right it's very rare yeah um
okay so my next question is what
disqualifies you from being a
housewife she belong to the streets
I'm going to go first only fans I would
say once you put your butthole on the
internet I'm sorry why it was butthole I
mean I just you know that's you know but
you don't have to show your butthole and
only fans you you show your toes yeah I
think all of that will disqualify you
from high value men yeah definitely okay
yeah okay what do you think name
something me yeah you we're going Circle
yeah oh okay um from not being a wife
housewife a housewife H if you're just
not if you're not ready for it it's not
your bag no no no I'm saying like what
would disqualify the woman so like the
woman comes to him and says I want to be
your house I want to be your housewife
what would disqualify
her onions
bions I'm Jing I'm Jing hi
feet it's true
she can't cook I don't know I was going
to say that but she will say but she
could she could like have a maid to cook
for her she's like who needs to cook
she's going to have a maid I I just saw
that in your face I mean is that really
like I don't think that's like a n break
yeah I knew it I just got back from
Nigeria my mind is blown cuz Nigerian
men pay for their living you don't pay
for anything when you're in Nigeria
they're a whole different level she's
like
yeah
all right so can't all right so give me
a deal breaker then give me one I
there's nothing a chick can do nothing
okay if she's a corn star
okay thank you for remembering that
thank you go ahead my
day what would disqualify you bad money
management over spending yeah he's going
to be really rich no no no you got you
can't you still got to like relax like
next month as well
like exactly overspending yeah okay go
ahead if she's a
cheater cheater or
lesbian that could be an advantage they
like that I know people that love that
situation when they have freedoms I
don't know I think this someone for
everyone you know all those things
they're listed I think someone was still
well there's only housewife positions
for 10% of women okay infertile
um you say that yeah okay I I'll go with
that but I would agree with that yeah
but unfortunately but yeah so so by that
logic over a certain age over say just
I'm just saying iner somebody else can
that what if they are infertile but hope
to like have other treatments to have
children or even adult it depends if
he's patient for that you know but per
was saying like if they're like
premenopausal yeah well well I'm well
age somebody can say age yeah well
because I'm saying also um I mean why
would a man choose that if he didn't
have to like this is a guy with all the
choice um okay so we we're sticking at
high value men disqualifying a housewife
for a high value man okay yeah I mean I
I feel like I spoke to two randomly two
men recently that were saying that they
went through the whole IVF thing with
their women I don't know how high value
they were but they weren't low value so
I don't know think some men consider
that but again I'm sorry were they
successful I do believe they were
successful yeah you do believe or you
yeah I don't know that's what I said I
don't know they were high value but they
were absolutely not low value but they
were but don't you don't you think they
probably don't you think they probably
found out that she couldn't have kids
specifically told me his whole life
story on this flight and it was like no
they knew before that she was going to
have trouble having children they
decided to get married you really got
into on that FL yeah St talking to me
but he was adorable but yeah
did you did I
what three times no I I I did not
anything
um where were we where were we in the
circle you you did you go did you go I
just I just took um Miss Ling's answer
for the infertility because I I guess
for a high value man if he's trying to
expand on his if Offspring with
his M expand his name yeah with his
legac
legacy to pass it down over what age are
you disqualified from being a housewife
I don't know CU this is a thing I I just
think it's such a broad vague question
because guys so in general we know so
there there's going to be exceptions to
every rule so we're just talking in
general we're not talking about the one
chick there but like by by and large by
the rule over what age are women
disqualified from being a housewife 1 do
you think yeah I think so what if you
marry a man like
6 and you could be in your 40s you're
still a young thing to him and he he the
high value guy as well right but you've
probably already been a housewife once
or twice
prior but but by 60 probably he's
probably married he probably so he's
like high value by 40 he's divorced and
he's looking for a new new
beans and then and then you're like
divorce young to him cuz you're like in
your 40s and you look good for your age
you're better than him okay you do you
know what percent chance do you know
what percent chance you have of a man
marrying over the age of 35 if he hasn't
already
0.3% oh don't 15% chance he marries and
Before Troy so there still there're
still 50% charg
no what about before then these these
statistics are based on people that are
actually being honest like what are
these numbers it's just like and it's
and in the UK as well
because UK UK and us are pretty similar
so I mean there sometimes there's a
little differentiation it's what people
report is it not like the actual
registry can't they just look that stuff
up yeah yeah yeah so it's pretty getting
husbands in what what is it below what
is it below I don't know off the top of
my head I in Nigeria honestly girls you
married you get married tomorrow Nigeria
what about you um not being
attentive okay not being attentive go
ahead super revolting personal
hygiene okay
smelly okay going to go for something so
obvious being selfish selfish
okay I'd say
liar
selfish liar there's some basic ones I'm
surprised no one's getting let's see if
you get it um who God no pressure no
pressure um sorry I wasn't ready being a
hoe know you was going to say
that my go these hoes ain't no you can't
a ho into a
house is word tried he tried exactly he
did what he could yeah that wasja Vu
okay okay I want to see you have to get
try well I don't know BPD I think
personality personality disorders CU
otherwise you end up with Amber herd
right yeah right my God so like
addictions you could probably put under
the same thing if she's drug addict if
she's like well if she's a drug addict
or she's an alcoholic that's going to be
a problematic if she's using and if
she's got
um and if she's got um that kind of
personality disorder I mean if you could
identify before she's definitely not in
the field for being a housewife okay so
I'm going to I'm going to add some of
mine yes Enlighten us yeah yeah so
number one you can't be
fat yeah yeah that's why you will not
get in the
door
consider UK 10 and over um I would I
would say look up your BMI and if it's
over that's that's rule of thumb I know
I know there's exceptions right I know
there's the women that have the very
shapely whatever mhm cuz I was toing pH
fat yeah I was like yeah we fat oh
no but yeah there's none of this like
thick where it's like the girls pretend
they're thin yeah but they're really fat
I think you need to ask a Nigerian
producer is it a producer there because
he I'm sure what's your preference we're
all skinny to you aren't we
yeah the
Bigg I mean PE Pearl and I argue about
this all the time this is the thing so
this is it's like when the doctor goes
you're obese and you're like
huh but still no fat things still though
what is fat in your per fat is fat is it
like a what size what size is that is
that it's that it's that size it's like
I think if you're fat you know your fat
though yeah it's I think his fat and
your fat is very different are you
talking about over P fat and his
Nigerian standard we like curvy
women but it's curvy but you think it's
a small waste though don't you yeah it's
always there's European fat there's
Jamaican fat and there's African fat
African they're all
different men men do like a bit of meat
on them now look it look it I'm not even
disputing that men like curvy women I'm
saying they don't like fat women some
men like skinnies women my friend is
really really skinny and like when we're
out certain men just gravitate towards
her cuz she's cute and she's like a twig
some men love twigy women like oh she's
so
heroin I the heroin you you don't like
the Cake Boss back in the day M you're
not number number two that disqualifies
you from being a housewife a child
another man's child now yeah now now I
know Sierra pulled it off but do you
look like Sierra probably not right yes
we do
see I look like miss you know I can't
see
it all right so so I would say a child
in general disqualifies you from being a
housewife not even it it will definitely
it will definitely impact it somewhat I
don't think that uh a guy will
completely dismiss you for it but it
will impact it somewhat because they
know that's an additional um person they
have to provide
for then they've got the this the your
child's attitude
yeah what what person what per of single
mothers
remarry uh if they want to
6% higher than that slightly 16 what 16
no cuz Okay off the top of my head I I
know what roughly was it was between
like 10 and like eight like 177% it was
somewhere between there 22% of single
mothers get guy to live with them so
overwhelmingly 60% roughly of single
mothers do never get a guy to live with
me now give me one
[Laughter]
hour I don't a couple in the
carck there's a couple waiting
outside there's a couple in Heretics
right now look it I don't I don't know
what to tell but also but this is
housewife right so this is like
housewife status this is the best of the
best women but I would say some women
that have kids cuz I know that if I had
kids I would be very reluctant to just
pick up with any man so maybe some women
for the sake of their kids they don't
want to expose them to certain people so
they're just like for now I'm just going
to be single and not have another man in
my household I think I think that's
admirable actually I I think it's better
for the kids I think that affects the
statistic definitely cuz I know that
there will be women that will think
disagree I disagree I
think the
way most wom we said high value men I
think I think it's the other way around
I think a lot of women would immediately
start looking for another man to
replace
way
aing we're not we're not talking about
see the thing about women is you guys
always think that your situation is what
what goes around in in society but if
you look at society and look at what
actually happens I a single there a lot
of irresponsible women out there
yeah but I do feel like when you have a
child like that child has to come first
so you have to be very careful who you
bring around your child and I know that
would definitely you know affect my
decision I totally I totally agree with
you but I don't think most single
mothers are
responsible I'm a single mom I'm a
single mom and there's no way I would be
rushing into any relationship with any
man like I'm very protective over my
daughter there's no way you got a
daughter
even when you got a son because I say I
would say I would say if single mothers
were responsible by and large then the
most likely person to abuse the kid
wouldn't be the next man if it's not the
mother it's actually the mother is the
most likely but second most likely is
the the main anally you do hear a lot
about guys who are on dating app they're
they're meeting single moms and the
single mom is and the single mom is then
like oh you know how do you feel about
you know I've got a kid and like and
they're sort of angling for somebody to
become the new baby daddy you know I
mean again
that's not
statistic there's also the dad still
active I would say there's also men that
actually pray on single mom because I
think for being General I don't think a
lot of men are out here looking for
single mothers I don't Absol you're not
looking for a mother like um I mean I'm
33 years old and I've never I've never
had any conversation with anyone any guy
and they're going oh you know what let's
get that single single mother no you're
not looking for a single but there are
there are
some ominous men out here that they they
pray on so about the high
value there's a lot of men out here that
are just trying to bum off rich women as
well that's a new phenomen yeah that
nowadays I think men men they're like
trying to women women wanted equality
here you go here you go Sugar Mama yeah
a sugar
mama if eat here as well I think I think
that's I I think that's admirable I mean
I'm absolutely in the market for a sugar
M for
100% I I can always go to the gym and
look good you better exactly but I would
agree with you I would agree with you I
don't think there's many guys who are
out there actively looking for single
mothers I think it's a bit more like you
know you meet the girl and then she
turns out to be a single mother and
you're like yeah well okay maybe I can
Overlook that for mean after after you
breed her leave her exactly exactly if
there's a connection then yeah you're
open to whatever can happen but you're
not actively seeking a single mom but
she just happens to be a single mom
you're not actively seeking a single mom
but some men are I'm
saying heard
stor I understand what you're saying
though I think what you're saying is the
men that looking for single mothers
because they feel it's family no I'm not
even saying it's an easy shag I'm saying
when she was doing when she was saying
about the the the the statistics and I
was saying but in that there are some
men that actually pray on on single
women because they want to be around
their kids yeah
oh that's a small percentage of that's
like a tiny percentage of there's load
of pedos out there
mate a tiny percentage actually actually
I think that women actually pray on
young men more than men pray on young
women I
[Laughter]
disagree young men always chase me and
I'm just like I don't chase young men
they chase me ie I'm talking about like
um I I see it more commonly now where a
woman gets in trouble for sleeping with
a student than vice versa you see them
all the time in the news I think they're
mentally ill cuz I don't know why they
would want to sleep with a child most of
my friends growing up that that lost
their virginity as little kids all
losted to older women same with the guys
I know as
well would you go younger Kelly then I
have dated younger but I wouldn't date
someone underage or like not underage
but if someone was juvenile to me God
knows what about what about 23 24
definitely not actually I have I have a
question I have a question kind of
pertaining to this who's more sexual men
or
women men
women women wait wait wait wait guys
okay we have to go one at a time one at
a time and then tell me why you think
that so here I would say women cuz I
think we're very sensual we're very
emotional and I think that when we're in
the throws of passion we're we're kind
of led by that sensuality oh
yeah go ahead I'm also saying woman wow
okay women why I think also emotionally
we're just more attached to that kind of
stuff so okay I think men why right
because men men can just have so many
different partners and have like so much
sex sexually yeah and I just think they
could just go from one to the other and
just not even worry about their mental
connection like yeah I would say men
also because I saw this um documentary
where there was this woman that she was
um like trans she wanted to
trans into a m a male who
laughed but anyways that's what she was
doing and um she said like as as a woman
her sex drive was healthy and then when
she started um taking taking she like oh
my God my sex drive went through the
roof I think
hormonally um men were going to feel
more yeah definitely sorry P say what
was the question again who's more sexual
men or women oh okay men I think
definitely men I think you're right
because they can just bang it bang bang
bang bang see okay this is this is
what's got me I I can
honestly I could honestly be convinced
either way but I've started to think
it's women and the reason I think it's
women this is just my
thoughts we talk about relationships
24/7 it's like when we're with our
friends and what what do women talk
about boys but not sex though that's
like power struggles that's like oh my
God he didn't do this or he did this
well yeah but I think we seek attention
and men seek sex and that's what we get
like validation that doesn't make us
more sexual though does it I would say
yes I think I would say because the ways
we seek attention is sexual and wearing
tight clothes taking off our clo like
dressing very sexually I would say is
how women seek seual attention oh yeah I
think if you go into a gym um that the
clothes that women wear today would have
been banned like 20 years ago um in some
cities like Vegas and America the women
wear like stickers on their
boobs you go to bikinis like when I was
growing up most people wore one pieces
and then like the bikinis were kind of
like out there now we're in thongs
people us to get sent off the beach for
bikinis didn't they yeah do you know the
other thing as well I don't know if you
guys have ever read the book uh My
Secret Garden by Nancy Friday but it was
this book that came I think it's I think
it came out in the' 70s or the ' 80s but
it's this book of sexual fantasies that
this psychologist collected women's
sexual fantasies and I mean some of the
stuff in there is frankly crazy you know
this is some of the stuff that am I able
to Google it yeah yeah my my secret
guarded by Nancy Friday it's really it's
really eye opening to read and the other
thing of course was the 50 Shades of
Gray phenomenon you know best s book
ever you know and it was his complete so
I think that while I agree on the point
about testosterone and yeah guys like
bang bang bang whatever but I think
women once they get into it they're
really [__] into it they're really
into the whole fantasy the seuality of
it I think probably more than let's be
honest men want to just get their end
away and then have a cigarette and you
know go go to sleep whereas women they
get much more bought into the whole you
know the whole drama of the whole thing
bit more depth in it with with women I
think bit more
passionate changing your answer now no
no cuz we I still say men I still say
men you still say men okay what do you
think men or women I was going to say
both but I do think it is women because
I feel like I do think it's women
because I feel like with ources too we
use our our looks we use like obviously
in terms of the way we look um when a
guy approaches us and all of that we
could be come across very seductive at
times I think I think it's women who
breathed like that into the
mic one of rules one of the rules don't
breathe into I I was getting carried
away I was getting away a man obviously
no no but I think I think it's just like
what if I talk to guy friends and
they're like oh yeah I met this girl and
you know yeah she came back to mine and
yeah we banged or whatever it's very
sort of perun and it's like right yeah
we did that with women and then when I
deal with women it's very sort of like
they go into this and took me against
the
wall it's just even when I when I when I
dealt with women that that I maybe I've
dated and stuff like that that like
there's just so much more to us this
this whole like sexual like fantasy and
this kind of imagination and everything
and he didn't say good night babe he
sent me a smiley emoji with h
eyes we it's got be it's got to be the
over doesn't it the over oh yeah because
shops like an I still think it's men
because I feel like everything we've
just described is like a woman uses sex
to get the emotional connection to get
the spiritual connection when we are in
our bag we're so Central because we're
trying to get to that place and I kind
of rape men for being able to be like
this is sex I'm going to do it here it
is love it all right cool move on
whereas women it's always like I'm doing
this for this and that and this and then
uh like about the sex yeah but no just
out of interest do you genuinely think
that or do you not think that the women
are actually getting off on that as well
I think women are sexier than men right
but I think men are more sexual than
women like if it was like a man's going
to give me like the spiritual and
emotional connection I thought I would
get if I was having badass sex with him
then I would probably just do have that
conversation what is what is the
spiritual and emotional connection
that's when you're like looking at him
and it's like de this is it we are so
connected we are like you know you just
look at a guy and you're like so
connected it's like bring adding more
meaning to everything because you're
having this great time and it's like
yeah so if you were to tell a guy he
says I want to make a spiritual and
emotional connection how would you do
that if he just like wanted to he sat me
down and he was like I'm just like so
[__] into you I think you're great
and I think we're going to have this
amazing life together and he just again
the fantasy thing he he leaned into all
the fantasies of this wonderful life I
want to live then I'd probably like just
like do women I'm black and white do
women do women I have a question I have
a question do women typically like the
men that like them or that don't like
them um typically don't I would say okay
so aren't you giving them the wrong
advice then giving who what advice the
guys when I asked you how to give you a
a spiritual and emotional connection for
me oh for you for me I don't I don't
know about anyone else but for for for
me there's going to be a lot of boxes he
needs to tick in the first place place
and then there's going to be the life
and the fantasy and and the experience I
want I think I like with a lot of
women's advice it's probably you would
want that but you would want that from a
dude that you're already attracted to oh
hell yeah yeah don't like chat me up on
Tinder and be like I'm want to get into
your mind yeah yeah so if
like so if he's like Chris Hemsworth or
whoever right and or whoever you like
and he's coming out with Chestnut and
he's coming out with this stuff then
you're going to be into that Chestnut
ain't go do [__]
you but that's the problem that's that's
the problem with female that's the
problem with female dating advice though
sometimes when it's a at guys because
women will say well we want a guy who's
this we want a guy who's honorable who's
Noble Who does these things he shiver us
blah blah blah and guys think right I've
just got to do those things but actually
it's about so much more than that
because women want it from the guy that
they're already attracted to and I still
sex and I still want to have sex we want
we want men that are good in bed and
know how to like treat us well but also
good but would I use it as much if I
felt like I could connect with you on a
different basis I don't think men are
capable of connecting the same way women
can so I don't know if I would well I
feel like I'm more basic than that I
actually think think I think men connect
better than women fact they're more way
I think I think men are women are a lot
more heartless where men actually have
hearts absolutely actually actually I
think you're right because I think men
get upset because can break their heart
and sometimes I think men can take
things like really to their heart after
after they broken yours yeah but women
can just forget about it but have you
ever like let someone down and they're
absolutely heartbroken and they really
take it in don't they when they're
heartbroken what do they do when they
take it in what is the characteristics
of a man that's taking s into a heart
yeah so tell me did you know when you've
just like you know you're not bothered
with them and that youve they've taken
you out on a date and you just they no I
can't be bothered with him he's not my
sort of type of guy and he's absolutely
wounded because they take it to heart
you can tell you're speaking from
personal experience here and there's
some poor bloke who's watching this now
going
[Music]
no the
date I'll tell you I'll tell you why I
think I think women are more heartless
because the amount of women that I've
met that left their the father of their
children because they outgrew them is
just like ridiculous I've met so many
women that have that have left the
father of their kids broken up their
entire family because they outgrew their
husband yes but ultimately I feel like
the fact that they outgrew them that the
man was probably more heartless than
them in the relationship where they felt
that they had to I think I know I think
I think when women want to do something
they make up any excuse they can to do
it and I think and I think typically the
women are not innocent a lot of times
they play not say women Innocent but
having outgrown somebody I feel like
things like I mean the fact that the
term outgrow is that they're still quite
juvenile in some aspects and in that in
and in that I feel like men can just be
really callous sometimes and just really
not kind of like elevated on their
levels of like caring and just can I
have an example
um so I feel like women are more
obviously women are more emotional and
women are more kind of like um mature
yeah mature no I disagree I say emot I
going say emotionally maturee I disagree
I think women are more emotionally
immature you think so I think we have
all this propaganda we are the Russians
that more like sensitive I'm not going
to lie I think women I think women stop
aging like mentally when they when they
hit their like um attention Peak so if
women like become pretty at 16 I think
they they just stay 16 forever I think
most women mentally are in high school I
just got I mean you know potato p
but you know I feel like yeah in that
aspect for the point I'm trying to make
is like if you're with a guy and he's
emotionally immature so he might do
things that are very juvenile like
you''ll be like oh I'm looking after the
kids like I'm going out with the boys
and you're like but what about the kids
like oh you know you sort it out and
when I get back or you know them ones
when you're like oh I'm going out on
Friday he's like I'm going out on Friday
and you're like oh who's going to love
the kids you get a babysit okay wait
wait wait so the the big issue is that
he wants to go out with the
boys you asked for an example I'm giving
an example because that's I find that
with a lot of relationships women will
say to me like the man will expect me to
get a babysitter it's like the kids are
my job it's on me as opposed to it's an
equal thing like oh we both booked the
same day how are we going to sort this
out okay because because you're a mom it
should be are you supposed to that's
your job you both had those kids
together and
actually the solution out did I did more
I carried them for N9 months I breastfed
them they came
but the men typically pay more so even
in 50/50 relationships they still pay
more typically I've been a bread winner
in many relationship so that's alleged
yeah but I'm not I'm not talking about
you but I'm saying I disagree that I can
speak of myself I can speak of myself
right but we're talking about like if
you are in a single mother home you're
at every statistical disadvantage ever
right no you are you're more like I
could be a millionaire but I just a go I
I just have my kids by myself no no I
mean well it doesn't even matter like
money doesn't replace a father I think
we've seen that with Kim Kardashian when
you see the clips of the kids now and
they're kind of going crazy but you're
but you're attributing it to the fact oh
the guy must have done something wrong
and it's blah blah blah but that's what
people that's what women will often say
when these conversations come up but is
it that or is it the woman's just got a
bit bored she's like oh we're a few
years in Devil's Advocate the sex has
got a bit boring you know the grass is
may be greeder on the other side the
personal Trader from bloody you know
virgin active or whatever is pretty hard
we get you know the grass is the grass
is greener right and that seems to me to
be what happens more often than not I
think social media kills
relationships social media kills
relationships years ago I think when
there there was no social media there
was no phones people were still cheating
in you just didn't find out until their
funeral when came
the and everything that you speak of you
found out at their funeral keeping it on
the lad that's
I I think it's allowed women to just be
like openly look for new men when you
when you look at Instagram profiles
today that's what it is and that's why
and that's why I was sort of saying when
I was saying before about being married
and like not being on social media I
mean I'm not some like red pill like you
know thumping the table women shouldn't
be on Instagram I'm not really like that
but I do see the point because it's like
basically you're putting out sexy
pictures of yourself on Instagram even
if you're not but even if you're not
intentionally doing that that what's
that going to do it's going to attract
the attention of other dudes they could
be sliding into the DMS you know things
in your main relationship things in your
marriage getting a little bit dry a
little bit stale and then and then the
temptation's there it's been like well
you know you kind of see where you share
in the sexual Market I would never date
a man of Instagram yeah but the thing is
if you're loyal then it doesn't matter
how many DMS that you're getting yeah
but it kind of tells you like oh wow
like Michael B Jordan is into me you get
like an idea of like oh I'm still I
still got it you know what I me and then
someone else
if you're a
Loy if if you're loyal then you're loyal
it doesn't matter if anyone's slipping
into your DM if you love your man you
love your man you will not cheat on if
you're if you're loyal if you're loyal
but how does the before the guy goes
into the marriage or even before the
woman goes into the marriage how do you
know that they're going to be loyal and
how do you know they're going to be
loyal over the long
term you got to have faith you got have
faith
but women but women by and large are not
loyal women I mean even when women win
the lottery they leave their husbands
they tend to when men win the lottery
they tend to stay I don't know who these
people are that you're talking
about age age it's not just the lottery
it's also when women get promoted at
work they're more likely to divorce
where men are more likely to
stay when women get leverage um in the
relationship they tend to leave men when
they get leverag they tend to stay okay
cuz probably the woman leveraged that
man up to that position and the woman
happens to be with that guy at that
position and then she leveraged up
herself but didn't but didn't he
leverage her probably not so
statistically but I I want to show like
this is gynocentric thinking so there's
gynocentric propaganda like gynocentrism
basically is women are amazing and
special and more awesome than we are
whenever a man accomplishes something we
always attribute it to women but
whenever a woman accomplishes something
we never attribute it to the man she's
with but did you not say that women are
less likely to succeed in their own
companies so obviously so then they're
not being supported by men so that means
no I would I would say women only
succeed when they are supported by men
typically so like Kim Kardashian didn't
become a billionaire until she was with
Kanye it's like a trend that I see where
it's like when women come successful
typically they have a strong man behind
them somewhere this is why they're
leaving them because women typically are
supporting men and then men are
typically not supporting women so that's
why leaving them support her no yeah I I
would I would say the men are supporting
the women and a lot of times the men
support the women and get them to a
certain point and then the women leave
cuz women are hypergamous you know women
always want the guy to be above them so
you hit that you hit that level what's
that word hyper hypergamous hyper you
took me a new word today thank you there
you go so it's hyper how you spell that
hypergamous so hypergamous thank you
I'll give you another example of a trend
that I see cuz the biggest thing is I
kind of just look for patterns in like
society and relationships and just like
trends that I see one of them is women
politicians they always seem to get like
they get elected into an office and then
they they screw someone at
work there there's a girl in the US that
this just happened with Lauren bobert
something bobert she had four kids she
literally gets elected one baby daddy no
yeah one one one a husband
Maybe daddy but then she divorces her
husband and then like 6 months later
she's in the movie theater with some guy
and like went super viral did you see
that you know what I'm talking about
yeah well Liz truss got voted into
office in the UK and she screwed the
whole country politic
political
there yeah you like do you like it cuz
she she T the economy and then she got
chucked out
so well that's why that's another Trend
I see like why I say women are bad at
business and typically leadership roles
all of the shortest um terms of like
Prime Ministers and presidents are all
like typically women she was she was she
stayed like two days like really that
not because men have had more
opportunities that's what that's what
they say women have more opportunity
than men in 2023 and we just still kind
of suck with it it's only 2023 that
you're gauging off of isn't it so maybe
in another decade then you can give her
more no that's what they say like 50
years it's no it's been like 50 years of
this so we've had 50 years of like
women's empowerment and we super short
but that's very short patrio and at the
end of the day let's have this
conversation again when we're like come
back with our Z what did you everyone
here is under 50 right well yeah right
except so so I'm saying everybody's
lifetime has had a ton of women's
empowerment so you need a little bit
more a I was I was Li how was in if you
were you're saying that women's
empowerment but I was alive when there
weren't any black people on the TV so I
feel like the women's empowerment came
after the black people TV in what era
even now in when I was young there was
hardly any black people on the T you
born in the UK yes now there's black
people everywhere on the TV like
literally Comm the phone would ring
because they oh my God there's a black
person on the TV and I feel like this
kind of empowerment of women and like
that's come after the black people on
the TV take time it's going to take time
I don't I don't like I don't like
women's empowerment I think it's
actually really insulting I I to women I
think it's very insulting because you're
saying we need special treatment and
privileges to do things more
opportunities we just need more
representation treatment we just need
need to be yeah it's very we all have
feelings we have emotions we all have no
of course we do you say no no
no did the exact same thing as that
female politician but I'm shaking my
head is to you when you said we need
representation I'm saying no I don't
think we do need representation I think
we need qualified people that are smart
and competent and I think we keep
putting women into positions we're not
good at well maybe they putting these
certain women into position women the
wrong women to this position is to to
make an example of them see this is what
happens when you put a woman in this
position because again it's still a
patriarchy and I ultimately feel like I
I disagree women have not had the
opportunity to so you don't think women
should be put in in in positions of
power but you don't think that it's a
patriarchy I think I think it's a
matriarchy actually I think women
typically live life une easy mode I
think a woman's life is much easier than
a man's life I think women no no so what
what I'll tell sta I'll tell you you you
you turn you turn 21 you have the option
to monetize your beauty that that's ugly
yeah um even an ugly woman gets more
attention than the average man I
disagree I'll give you an I'll give you
an example women rate we know we G and
guys though for real if you're pretty
women F ones women rate 80% of guys as
unattractive even if you're unattractive
I'll give you an example lizo has built
an entire brand off of being
unattractive she's not unattractive
she's just overweight I don't think that
she's not ugly she's got beautiful face
some men like some men like all that men
men don't by and large like fat chicks
some men do I'm saying like Okay if you
go back if you go back 50 years
right and she's not ugly if she was F
think she's ugly exactly so I don't
think she's a good a good example I
would say she's unattractive because
she's severely overweight in your
opinion I would say J Jamaican men love
I I think I think think you know I've
had I've had King do African men love
fat girl no you don't like lizo Jama man
love fat girls okay okay good good point
so what kind of Jamaican men like um fat
girls is it the ones that typically have
a lot of resources or the ones that
broke and don't have anything I'll be
honest and say I don't know the answer
to that but I know for a fact do that a
lot of Jamaican men love fat girl a lot
of guys feel that women with big
hips you if you look at all the most
successful men that have ever walked the
Earth how many of them have you seen
walking around with a fat woman also
maybe they like fat girls but because
going to guess I'm going to guess
something right now Trisha I'm saying
all the other successful men have SK I'm
gonna guess something I'm going to look
up Jamaica's richest
man okay I'm GNA I'm gonna guess I'm
gonna
[Laughter]
guess a good question and let's look at
what the men with the most choice pick I
have no idea andca I could be I could be
wrong his including his side Michael
Michael leein is one of them so I'm
going to pick this guy let's see let's
see what his wife looks like Michael
leein and it depends on your definition
of fact because what you may think is no
no no guys we know but again you know
some men like big women not a fat chick
not a fat chick but half Chinese there's
a huge Chinese I mean I get I think when
we have conversations about um women um
actually forgot we have conversations
about men liking big women we should
also factoring if we're making the
argument then we should also argue that
women like short men like they're going
for short
men I'm leaving why why you some women
do like so why are you having that
reaction to women tolerates short men
but they don't necessarily
like I have friends that like short men
she's looking she's
like but but she's cuz she's short so
she doesn't like me okay so that's but
she's she's right though in the same way
like women tolerate short men men
tolerate fat women it's the exact same
some men like fat women they don't women
like I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
tell you why that's not true because
when you look at the men with the most
choice if you say if I say okay if I'm
broke and I say I don't like Gucci bags
well you're broke of course you don't
freaking like Gucci bags yeah but I also
so if you look at so if you look at the
men with the most Choice the most
ability to choose I just looked up
Jamaica's richest guy I know you said he
was half Chinese but he's still half
Jamaican too right he he has a thin wife
but I feel like I also feel like there
are people that when they get to a
certain position like for example and
I'm going to use again like a lot of
black footballers when they got to a
certain position they all D dated white
skinny models yeah be prior to them
being footballers they weren't dating
white skinny models but when they got to
a level get white skinny models no but
they felt like but they felt like it was
the status qu so they felt like that's
what they were expected to do I
don't the that's the case it supports
this AR that's a narrative women tell
themselves because of what they see
happen that's a narrative I've been told
by these footballers actually they feel
like they're more accepted they're more
accepted as a black man when theyve got
a skinny white woman by their SI when
they become a rich black guy they can
actually date certain white girls so
they give that a go no but also like
they feel more socially accepted I don't
believe that any guy dates somebody
seriously for the social credit that
they get for that I think you say that
as a soci Reas you say that as a white
man Troy I'm saying as a black man when
he's in certain environments to feel
socially accepted he sometimes feels
like he has to have a skinny beautiful
white woman in his arm instead of
bringing a black woman on his
arm I actually say I agree with you he
sometimes feels he needs a skinny woman
not
that there are too many black women that
are just overweight so less skinny black
women to pick from that's the
reality he makes he makes a good point
because because what about a skinny
black woman because I've dated various
black women who were who were quite
slender and quite shapely that that's
great but but I I would agree with the
general sort of concept here that that
fatness is just not sexy for guys right
whether they're black whether they're
white whether they're Asian you know
whatever some men like fat women you
kind of R talking about the majority
some women like short men but it's not
the majority MH but it doesn't matter
we're just talking about what floats
your boat could be a rich ites it does
it does matter it does matter and the
reason it matters is because if you keep
lying to women about what men want they
don't become what men want and half of
women are projected to die alone trying
to what just being me height you're boom
with that height isn't it but to to to
be a certain weight sometimes that why
do takes a certain actually I have a
question why do women lie to each other
about makes us feel better yeah like why
I don't know why you keep lying when you
know that men like thin women like I
know some men like thin let's just I
just
want men around the men around wait wait
wait wait no I just want I just want to
be real here you know that men prefer
thin women I've got a fat I've got a fat
friend I've got a fat friend she's very
beautiful yeah wait wait wait wait wait
you know that men prefer thinner
women you know you
know you
know out with a very very large girl can
I just say something really really quick
real real real quick I believe that men
prefer more of a woman in shape but
there are a small percentage that like
fat women
that's but my question is why do we sell
women dreams well no I'm not selling
anyone dream my the fact I say my friend
she a b girl she's very beautiful
beautiful girl and like she goes on
dating s sometimes and she'll meet a guy
and she'll be like oh you know when he
sees me in real life do you think he's
not going to like me cuz I'm fat and I
said babe you look fat in your pictures
he knows you're fat so when he's meeting
you he knows you're a fat girl so he
must like fat girls otherwise he's not
going on a date with
youit if I
go why wouldn't you tell her what would
help her which is that if you're
insecure about it you should lose weight
does go in a diet she does Diet all the
time but she's just a bigger girl and
she struggles to I'm saying I'm saying
one thing would help her if her problem
is that she thinks men are going to
think that she's fat the truth is the
truth is wait wait the truth is that
they will think she's fat and that the
truth is they will think she's fat
because even those men are not blind and
she should lose weight I feel like they
they can already see I have a lot of
clients that come into my salon that are
what's your what's your um I I have
clinics um around Essex and I have a lot
for what clinics
STD how did you
knows clinics and some of my larger
ladies have more confidence than the
smaller thinner ladies you know their
confidence is through the roof they
don't want to lose weight they're happy
in their so I don't I don't care about
confidence I care about results
and fat women have a harder time
attracting men and fat women are more
likely to die early and die alone right
that's no you see the problem the
problem the problem we're having here in
this Society is that women get very
confused very quickly because men will
give sexual attention to any type of
woman that is the problem so a woman
will sit here and argue yeah men like
fat wom because they know that men will
still sleep with because they know they
want to sleep go over a big fat bum
exactly and big reality think about it
if you to really think about it when
want to settle down they not going to
step out and pick the first fat woman
that they can find if you like fat girls
you like fat girls no I'll tell you why
I'll tell you why I tell I'll tell you
why most men that would do that are
probably very ignorant because the
reality is when you're overweight it
comes a lot of Health complications and
if you're choosing a life partner that
is you
literally picking potential future
problems okay what's the statistics
about how many how many larger women
there are in the country to how many
thin of the women are in the country um
I know in the US it's about the average
woman's 170 lb it's like average size is
like 14 or 16 in the UK right that's
what I heard yeah size 14 or 16 yeah
yeah and women are not getting married
as much as they used to it takes about 3
years to get an engagement from a guy
we're not having kids like we're used to
and we're not in relationships like we
used to not settling and it's I would
say that men are refusing to settle for
women I would say it's the other way
around I would say I would say that
women think they're the ones in charge
but we're really not because really uh
most women are just chasing after 10% of
men because the number one way people
are meeting now is Instagram and dating
apps women find 80% of men is
unattractive and ugly and I have a
plethora of women that tell me about
their ex-boyfriends that cheated on them
meaning that a lot of us are sharing men
meaning that really we're all just
fighting over a small percentage of guys
I we always set into different sta
Statics because that's probably your
statistic because I may not be trying to
chase that
oh actually let me let me let me that's
how you let me let me let me okay let me
let me break it down are you you have a
boyfriend yeah my status is private but
yeah it's completely private but yes I
do let's say either either either your
boyfriend now or your last boyfriend
let's say how tall is he um just an
irrelevant
hype be h HP hypothetically I would not
tend to typically go below six foot but
yeah okay so six foot how much money
does he make typically rich but
okay would you would you would you say
he's
good-looking very this is the thing
that's very subjective isn't it because
for me but the pause is telling okay
okay but I
know clarification I'll tell you okay
fine fine let's just say he's ugly even
if he's ugly six six I don't I don't
believe he is but let's just say he is
just just for stats for stats okay so
this you're and does he make over six
figures the you said Rich so I don't
know what is Rich to you this is the
thing it's a ballpark figure isn't it
you know to one give me okay okay poor
over six figures he's a midet PO let's
go that she she's cing out no no come on
don't cap out
of average height and of average income
let's go okay no no I want you to be
honest I don't want to say let's just
say I just want I want to have an honest
athetic person no no because she
single you're not I know you're not
answering the question because I'm going
to prove a point you said over six foot
even by that alone you're only going for
15% of guys 15% of men are over six foot
this is General because I have had
partners of different heights and
they're probably top 10% goodlook
because women find 80% of men ugly
depends on
your it's not depends it's not depends
of course some people might think I'm
some people might think I'm attractive
nobody think no women women tend to so
they've replicated
these they've
replicated they have replicated these
studies and like um dating events so
like when people go oneon-one and do
like um speed dating you can even see
these you can even see these studies in
real time if you watch Like The Bachelor
or The Bachelorette if you watch any of
those love Island shows they're always
competing for the same guys I've had
some guys that people think are actually
hideous looking and I think they're the
sexist thing
but proba rich don't play with us that's
they're rich no but even even if there's
a little bit of a disagreement if you
think oh he's oh he's all right looking
he's still in the top 20% of men the
reality if if if if women really thought
beauty was subjective women won't be
swiping right 5% of the time on in on
Tinder this is the
thing yeah pill and confidence for me
reality is Da apps dating apps tell the
truth when it comes to beauty standards
I'm telling my opinion my op never been
on but but guys you could do the same
thing with Instagram you could do
everyone has Instagram here right I'm
assuming that's how you get recruited
right although by the by the way I would
say what they just said is an argument
for people doing cold approach like
approaching your real life I mean you
maybe you disagree Paul because you're
saying that the real life studies sort
of bear out the online stats but I do
think when you approach your real life
you tend to get a few additional points
as a do you're not going to get you're
going to
100% interaction in a picture you might
not be you might not be to that point
any guy who is confident enough to
approach a woman in public is probably
top 10% of men because he has been doing
it I'll tell you I'll tell you why a guy
a guy who is not attractive and who
doesn't get women is not just going to
out of the blue approach
ATI you you guys don't live the life of
a man I'm telling you King we live the
life of women that men approach yes I'm
and I'm telling you that and I'm telling
you that the men that approach you and
I'm telling you that the men that
approach you have been successful at
approaching other
women
allegedly okay okay I just okay sh okay
request so you really think that if a
man has approached 100 women and all of
them have rejected him you would accept
him no he would it's possible it's
actually impossible I tell you for the
fact that for the fact that 100 wom
unless unless you're telling me think
about it think about not impossible we
get ched out all the time Pearl wanted
to say something what did you want to
say pearl um so question I like ugly men
by the way who here who here has had a
boyfriend that's cheated on them cheat
okay probably all right everyone [__] me
too all right we're sharing that's the
point we're sharing men we're literally
sharing B yeah but who has cheated on
their
man when I was young when I was young I
was young but I Che look if we want to
argue that women if we want to if we
want to argue if we want to argue that
women are promiscuous this is the show
everyone cheat actually fin no no no but
the point the point the point is the
point is it's still a small percentage
of men that we are going after that is
the point and my point is you are lying
to your friend you're lying to women by
always doing by always yeah you are you
are Society is set up you have you can't
it's not I don't call it lying it's the
way that Society is set up you can't
tell somebody that they're unattractive
or you need to go and lose weight or
because no you can't she's not
attractive the problem yeah exactly the
problem but the problem the problem
you're having is but I'm saying like you
need to be honest with women and I'm
saying I don't understand why you keep
arguing for the exception no but I was
honest I told her she's fat I said that
okay but would you would you also be
able to tell her that the majority of
men you're beautiful if a man sees you
on your TW Tinder and he sees your body
shape cuz you show it your and he wants
to go on a date with you when he sees
you real laugh is oh she's fat no
but but but her pool of potential dudes
would be bigger if she SLI down a bit
and that's by The Bu but the point I'm
making is when she her story she wants
to maximize her opportun her question to
me was do you think when they meet me
they'll be like oh she's fat and I said
no because they can see your fat from
your pictures and they Sorry bab and
they've CH still chose chose to go on a
date with you so they must like fat
girls no no what I but that's not what I
was I was referring to during this show
I keep saying that men don't like fat
chicks and you keep arguing with me some
men before you're right you keep arguing
with me for the for the exception and
I'm saying that's dishonest so if I say
that if I say that and I'll tell you why
if I say that women like rich men you
know you could say but some women like
broke men you know that would be I've
broke men I've been the bread wi in
relationship I I don't know if that's a
fle but my question my question is are
you with them now no exactly I'm not
with Rich
my point my point if they had the things
you were looking for you'd be with them
women don't leave the men that have the
things they wasn't the thing and lack of
money wasn't the thing it was obviously
it was obviously was something else cuz
i' still okay tell me what was it what
was it what was okay I know I want to
hear what was it so the last M
relationship I was in I just found him a
little bit emotionally detached
emotionally detached so this is what I
call things women make up when they
don't like the guy because he's not he's
not doesn't well I'm very tactile I'm
very emotional I'm very loving and I
just found him not to be that type of
person doesn't make him a bad person
just makes us very different people and
that's okay you can come to that
conclusion what you without knowledge
yeah how you
together
conclusion okay I gave it I gave it a
good run we gave it good Innings didn't
work it's okay so obviously come on
stripper how long was
you how how long how long has been your
longest
relationship uh about uh 6
hours about 6 hours 49 minutes when I
was flying from New York to London U and
most of it was conducted in the uh
toilets yeah yeah
yeah the physical intimacy didn't last
for the six hours by the
way I imagine I think if the but back to
wait sorry go ahead I think if the stats
are that most majority of men like a
woman
then is her is her mic off BL as a fat
woman as a fat woman you just say just
give up her love no but she can maximize
her PO well I I would say I would say
reality will hit you in the face anyways
and I I think a lot of times as women we
Shield each other from reality we say oh
you'll there's someone for everyone I
hear this all the time you realize 50%
of us will end up alone 50% of women are
going to be single
half of women are going to be single and
childless half of the um and that
doesn't even include the women that are
single mothers they don't typically
remarry really it's like less than I
would argue roughly 20% of women that
are predicted to have a happy ending so
what do you feel like Vision Bo wom
where do I um I think there's a lot of
people that lie to women I think women
lie to each other and like they often
make us like cope with poor choices so
for example the fat friend instead of
saying lose weight your life will be
better if you lose weight you'll be
healthier if you lose weight and you
won't be
insecure lose again and again I think
it's I think it's backed up um by the
media and they have an entire industry
dedicated to keeping us fat and alone
and they just want to make money off of
hold on a minute I have a friend one of
my best friends very large she's been
with our husand for years she's she's
fat she likes being being bigger was she
fat when they got married yeah there was
she was over over overweight when she
got married mared she's in a happy
relationship she's got two beautiful
kids she likes being bigger she's a
she's a model as well an influencer and
she's she's so happy and I love being
fat and I I think it's actually quite
selfish to be fat I think it's really
selfish because your kids are the ones
that are going to have to take care of
you so you're basically saying I don't
have any
self-control and now my kids you're not
going to have as long of a life with
your children not everyone's F because
of lack of self-control though so I
think that's very general
no what I would say You're fat because
you eat too much and you don't exercise
enough I hardly eat anything and I'm not
skinny like a twig so what does that
mean I would say that you probably eat
more than you say I think women probably
like women tend to lie about that so if
I if I had a dollar is definitely very
slim yeah no one car we're very very
honest aren we we're to the point of
being very blunt so it's like we're not
protecting anyone being sorry I'll be
say like oh Bab maybe yeah you could
look better be a bit more down that's my
sister she'll be like like what blunt W
bit fat now yeah triceps have got a bit
loose a bit tripy and honestly for me a
lot of guys that I um date they tend to
say to me oh when I'm training you've
you're too slim they don't like it MH
well I think they like I think men I
think 10% of men that you I think men
typically like slim thick yeah you know
you know they might like a big butt but
they have you have to have the small
ways it's like they've been like an hour
glass figure right who's Who's hotter
Aaliyah or lizo none
alah
obviously but no compar
comp but there's no comparison is dead
would you guys would you guys I have a
question if I have a question women
raise your hand if I said you have a
body like lizo would you take that as a
compliment raise your hand if yes no
this is what I mean when I say women lie
I would you no one said we want who said
we want a body like we just but but
point is before no but the reason I said
that is earlier I said that wima or
lizza I said that lizo was unattractive
and she said or I think there was a
couple of you maybe that said that lizo
is attractive I fa I say she's fat but's
pretty that's what I say facially we all
know that she's a baby hippo if you said
do I want Li's face this is a different
I would say the fat ruins her face
because there's all this blubber around
it I think she's
prettyy but she over be real she's
overweight though come on let's not deny
it exactly she's definitely overweight
so I would say I'm going to I'm going to
say so I think that the second I think
that the second thing that women like
lie to each other about and this kind of
goes to the housewife because for
whatever reason when I have these
conversations about like what what does
it take to deserve to be a housewife we
can always like talk about it in the
abstract but when it comes to reality
it's like we could never be honest um
and the second thing I think that we lie
to each other about is just how hard
women have it I think women have it
pretty easy especially compared to men I
think you mentioned a patriarchy earlier
I don't believe in that in the slightest
I think you're given far more
opportunity
your opinion babe um and I think
typically the women that argue about
patriarchy are usually just lazy I can't
lie I we have so easy and I'm so glad to
be a
woman
in I don't have to carry a baby forth we
have it easy and I think there's a
couple we have to carry the baby I don't
have to have
hormones I would say there's a couple I
would say there's a couple re a solid
relationship when it comes down to a
solid solid solid relationship between a
man and a woman who has got to do the
most providing technically a woman the
man that's the woman usually wants that
life more than the man anyways women
usually want kids more than the man and
want that we go into a club and we our
eyelids of
course easier yeah we have it 10 times
easier there's all these special program
I've been the bread winner in most of my
relationships so I don't see it like
that so well you're right but wa okay
what are you what you do again what do I
do yeah what do you do for a living I
dance on a
pole no no don't really I'm a singer and
I'm an artist perform okay well I would
argue that artists performers podcasters
social media influencers are all
monetizing their looks you absolutely
have an advantage as a woman as an
Entertainer po you know but I'm just
talking about being the bread being the
bread women in a relationship what we
say that what did you say you're a
podcaster are you like the podcasts
monetize their looks oh yeah know I
think I
think I think I think I think women have
it easier I think and I and I've managed
I could say this from managing I I've
managed social media accounts for women
and for men oh my gosh it's so much
easier if you're a chick chicks just
have to do some reactions they're like
no but if you're a hot man g go crazy
for that so I disagree well but but hot
men but men pay more
because no even as a hot
guy still have it easier because is
going to get up for a hot guy on the
train but they'll get up for a hot girl
on the train I would I would rather if I
had to manage one or the other I would
rather manage the average the SL the
cute chick over the hot guy it's easier
I'd manage a hot
guy can he sell more though can he
actually sell more than a woman can he
can he genuinely sell you more products
I mean if you look at if you look at
social media accounts I mean even guys
who are like his mic off guys can't even
guys is my can't he either the only
person in the it's some I can't hear
myself
either we didn't get to answer the
question there we've been going on about
you know who do you think's more sexual
I think I think the way the media can
everyone hear me I can hear not really
not in the
way it's what it is um so I think the
way the media sort of um has sort of
created this perception of life or
reality is you know right from When
We're Young growing up you know we we
see the images of men being very sexual
with TV American Pie Another Teen Movie
a lot of movies that just a lot of
things in media centered around men
being sexual but the reality is women
are more sexual and we see this
everywhere like on the train we see
women openly reading 50 Shades of Gray
but we whereas obviously men probably
IND doors watching corn but men are
women are more like liberated and sort
of have this sort of standard of being
able to to express discreetly that they
sexual and is accepted whereas men are
then seen by the society as this over
overtly sexual people and that's what
this all this image is about you know
men if a man is looking at you too much
you know they're probably thinking too
much about too much about sexual stuff
and things like that whereas the real
truth is like women are just more sexual
in my opinion I think that's where
feminism like makes it easier for women
then it's only now that we're seeing
content around women being
sexual I just I mean when you think
about it women we could when you think
bling I don't know what's going on I can
hear you can you hear me when you when
you think about it though it's like
women could have chosen to be anything
you know we got all this freedom and a
lot of us chose only fans there's more
only fans models than teachers right now
I'm a teacher I'm a qualified teacher
what about both men are they more only
fans men than men teachers are there
more women teachers than male teachers
what's the statistics I I want to know
so the male male to female teacher
breakdown there's far more female
teachers than male well we're winning
already then so we're win well I would
say that they're not winning because
women ruined education so in the 1850s
it was primarily male teachers and
you've seen IQ drop really since they
okay I actually have a child a CH since
having um a female teacher how do you
know that wasn't a change in the
curriculum as well well it did change
the so the problem is when women go into
a space and you kind of see it in this
conversation women don't like to have
hierarchy and rank each other so the
same way I'll say hey men don't like fat
chicks some of you are like okay yes
true but then like some other people are
like well but oh no women tend to like
everything to be more egalitarian Fair
everyone's special participation trophy
so when women infiltrate an industry it
tends to get more or it tends to get
less competitive what happened in
education is they started grading things
like papers homework and essays and
attendance which kind of fluff up the
grade where it used to just be IQ tests
so you don't think we should lead you
don't think we should teach do you think
that we should just be happy with the
average lives that and when I say
average it means like yeah I have a
house yeah I have things taken care of
for me but I can't customize that
life I didn't say I didn't say that
women shouldn't teach um I I just think
that women by and large are not as good
at teaching and they should be out of
the managerial positions that are making
decisions they should lead education or
in politics
yeah no I don't think women should be
should be led by men in all
Industries quick question but why okay
so I think there's a natural order in
the world um and this kind of goes I'm
Catholic so it kind of goes to a
religious point of view um I I I think
it goes God men women children and I
think when you start putting women above
men that is typically where you see evil
happen okay really yeah and and you see
it in society I'll give you an example
like before um really I just think
eality arianism is evil um and the
reason I think that sorry my voice is so
much louder it's like distracting me but
um so typically what what you'll what
you'll see is when women get power over
men they're just not nice with it even
when like women become queens and rulers
they're more likely to be violent when
women when women get power over children
they're more likely to kill them women
it's almost unheard of for men to kill
their kids in the first year women do it
all the time well and you were talking
earlier uh about female employers right
and even women prefer to have male
employers and I mean in my experience
working corporate right when there's
female bosses it's a it can be a
complete nightmare you know very
Machiavellian very dark Triad very sort
of like tough environment and the when
you have male bosses that could also be
a tough environment but it tends to be a
bit I hate to say it but it tends to be
a bit fairer and it tends to be a bit
clearer and sort of more above board you
know yeah even women don't exactly
exactly yeah I've I've worked with women
and they've said Jesus you know I wish
we had our previous well boss again
because this woman now is just a night
man well women have again women default
to
egalitarianism so men are much more
direct they prioritize information where
women prioritize our feelings
unfortunately so when you see women take
over an industry the industry tends to
go downhill an example of that is
education it used to be primarily male
and the results were much better now you
see IQ test dropping you have people
graduating high school they can't even
do basic math so typically when women
take over an industry just doesn't do as
well so do you not think that we're
evolving at all no I think I think I
think we're no I think we're I think I
think we're devolving and and I'll I'll
I'll answer that question I think we're
devolving I think women are getting
worse um and I I say that because I see
women in thongs at the beaches I I think
we're kind of prioritizing the wrong
things forget okay forget the the Min
minority that are in thongs and the
beaches however that's the majority so
so yeah I know I get this a lot
so
and there's women that do want to
elevate would I would say I would say
that the re the way the reason I have
been successful is I take a lot of
guidance from my dad I don't think I I
know I know your mom has nothing to do
with it my mom does not give me the same
type of guidance that my dad does she
boot so
so you know I mean they work together
they were they were a team but I I would
say my dad just men give you a different
type of guidance that has more structure
and that's typically what women need you
know I think I'm very I'm very my
brothers helped me too actually do your
brother get guidance from your mom or
your dad um typically I would I would
say for the things that require
structure they go to my dad because my
dad is very logical very structured he
can help me with the accounting he helps
me he helps me my housewife um my mom
actually quit her job she was going to
be a teacher and she quit she quit wait
she my my mom actually she
was my my dad owned a company growing up
and he was going to um my mom was going
to be a teacher and then she quit that
to go work for my dad to be a house and
they well they worked together they
built like their business together so I
mean it wasn't like a who did it it was
like a it was like a teamwork thing but
you know it wasn't like keeping score
house I get the foundation of your
knowledge and your how you feel but is
every one has a different upbringing
they have their part for us for my
sister and I we was
solid for my mom my mom worked um she
worked on a building site she had a
decorating company and she um took us
how many how many employees did the
decorating company have she had seven
okay yeah that's typically female
businesses are not over it is I know
however where was Dad times as well so
where was my dad we're evolving aren't
we was your your okay what happened your
dad they got he was not around he was
not around okay what they were divorced
they were okay what was were they dating
before like how how did you get to that
point he not around he was not around he
a relationship and not no but I'm I'm
asking like um were they together when
you were born the point isir wait wait
so I'm asking were they together when
when you were born that's no no it's
really it is really relevant they were
and when did when did he go out of the
picture I did okay and and this is based
off of like what your mom told you that
you know he's not around they both told
us he's now here for our lives yeah no
no I'm asking like have you ever spoken
of course he's he's a about now oh so
you you see him now yeah and what did he
say he's regret okay so he wasn't around
like he she like har should have been
and she stepped up to the plate yeah and
she done I'll tell you I'll tell you I
don't unfortunately everyone has that
different that
are are you saying that your life would
have been better with him there it would
have had a different level of of course
it would have two people two people
three people four people it shows you
well and it shows you the value of a
father and Men bring structure so we
agree for sure I wouldn't say that one
sex brings more value than the other
that's correct cuz if if our father had
done the same thing I don't think he
would have stepped up to the plate and
your mom wasn't around you EXA you would
you would have missed having a better
than one it takes a child to raise a
village my first question would was my
first question would be why did your mom
pick your dad it sounds like he wasn't
too good of a guy we're not in her head
her but that's that's my prob seual who
knows you know we don't know love you
bye baby what we need to do is get her
on the
show my point my point is I just think
that both sexes bring different values
and I think the value that men bring is
typically better in business because
they have more order women are very
creative I think women are more creative
a lot of the times no no I don't
sorry I was well I was I I thought about
that and then I started thinking about
all the like great architecture that
like men Freud and slip you think women
do have you know we you know what're
bosses really come on
come no I don't I think that if if women
were bosses the results would show that
do you think there anything that women
do better I tried for months to think of
something needs to be I tried I SW I
seriously tried so hard I thought we
were more nurturing and then I found out
the stats don't back it up like I'm big
like there has to be numbers and a way
to measure it well women are better at o
fans CU this female female fans creation
down
78% they ear 78% more than their male
counterparts on average so thank you
Troy thank you something we're better at
yeah we are they are better at sex work
no but that's that's not because women
are better that's because it's men that
pay for only fans well and actually try
try but here's here's the problem we're
not even better the top only fans models
are always managed by med yeah yeah and
the average is only 150 or whatever and
that's and that's my point like if we
were making all of this money and so
good at this stuff there would be
results you want to be just you want to
be a man well you want to be a man or
yeah what what do you feel comfortable
being a man because prer to be a man I
love being a woman honestly I think
because the men are so Imperial well I I
don't just because someone's Superior it
doesn't mean you're bad I think that
children I think that adults are
superior to children but children are
not bad you're not high value woman
though are you I you can't SE you've got
holes in your
socks I didn't even see
that but no no I think that the most I
think the most high value women are
married before 25 how do you know just
I'm over
25 but it's not it's not an insult guys
it's like it's the that's that's the
thing like the best women get married
before I I I that's that's not my point
though I'm saying just because it's like
if we point in an NBA player are you are
the wck Le is and say they're the best
or the wck is the wreck team mad no it
just is what it is everything has
hierarchy um so think people are entit
to their own opinion
no but I don't see I don't believe that
though I believe in results I believe
that there is an alleged status quo and
that's fine it exists statistics exist
but there are some men that like fat
women and
that's going by
results okay quickly guys just say
something going by results if we're
going by oh statistically blah blah blah
blah blah blah so you you're now out of
the statistics because you're not a high
value woman because you're out of the
statistics are you not high value well I
don't really believe that high value
women exist I I'll explain so so I don't
for one I I only believe that high value
women have to be selected by a high
value man so I again I I think that high
value men are only like 10% of men I
think it's very rare I think it's the
equivalent of say value no no I wouldn't
think that I am I I think I'm told no I
I think that I think I'm normal chick I
think most people are normal most people
are average it doesn't make you evil bad
it it just I think most people are
normal can I just say in the comments if
you like fat women can you just comment
that you like fat women you like normal
women give it up for the fat women in
fact fat women be considered normal
who's skinny nowadays we are normal she
just said herself if you're everyone's
normal it just there's a she said it
herself
so what I'm talking about
all of this prop all of this propaganda
like we just have so much marketing
towards us that's saying you're so
special amazing awesome like women call
themselves Queens like [__] you're
normal not everyone can be a queen
everyone's a queen I'm sorry I'm
everyone is a
queen don't like we even say we even say
princess treatment why why are you a
princess I want it some men think
picking up from the airport is Princess
treatment I'm just going to put that
there
standard Behavior standard protocol is
not confidence in yourself and what
you're doing 100% why would you not no I
I actually think that we have a society
that values confidence too much I think
humility is much more important yeah if
okay so if a guy said to you what you
only deserve McDonald's
girl like do you know actually you
deserve McDonald's girl I'm not high
value I just don't well I don't really
to be honest like I okay what is the
situation like why are we going to
McDonald in
your put up there I can go to McDonald's
that's fine I will go to Nando I will go
to Chipotle Nando is good oh Chipotle
that's my number one chipot I my number
did you see that little clip where we
were asking the dude if if Chipotle for
a first date and he's like no you can't
I don't care that's fine that's exactly
but you need don't don't disrespect your
yourself can I but what is what is I I
don't think it's disrespecting yourself
to be average
disr aage average everyone has a
different average for me if you say oh
I'm going to take you pound shop I think
everybody in this room is average I
think most people are average we're all
normal we're all human beings but if you
feel like
youcar
tomorrow average you have to go above
average if you want toess someone it
depends in me like right I know this guy
like oh he shops at 99 P I'm going take
this to the pound
store hey what are you talking about
there's no such fig as poundland anymore
poundland is like
250 but like you have to go above and
beyond that's what you prefer in the in
the guys that are you're dating is what
you're saying no you you I'm not saying
you need to go and take me to huh what
do you call I think I think the problem
is the ego it's the ego trap isn't it
you know we're all encouraged to be
super egotistical now and it's all this
you go girl you know it's my I'm I'm in
my queen phase or I'm in my princess
phase and all that [__] you
know I I suppose I guess I think what PE
you know like the reality is where most
of us the majority of people are just
just kind of average and that's okay but
we are encouraged as a society to be
incredibly egotistical to really puff
ourselves up particularly through social
media yourself is having is being
egotistical I think if you're ugly if
you're fat what you supposed to be
crying I'm disgus no but we're talking
about the princess treatment we're
talking about sof princess
treatment now there's even like dulu
humble what does average even mean like
say you're a beautiful person doesn't
necessarily apply to let it let's take
it another level when I'm I'm only
messing with people that are giving me
Princess treatment I think the
conversation is saying that maybe we are
alluding to a certain type of treatment
that not everybody
can as a culture As A Pup Culture
that if that's your bag
I agree I also agree but I think we also
need to admit that if everyone is saying
this a lot of these people are saying
this and they don't really know what it
means and they don't actually really
qualify for what they say if your friend
is fat and your friend is ugly you
shouldn't be say babes you're really
ugly though you're really fat why can't
you P saying like oh my in a world where
you can be anything be nice but you've
got to go back you've got to go back to
the statistic which is that only a
minority of women are going to get
married and have kids is that that's
correct isn't it women aren't going to
get married and have kids how about that
but why not why not OP why not optimize
your chances in the market though
because if being say bigger is going to
reduce the chances that you got in the
dating Marketplace doesn't it make sense
to at least address that because there's
going to be a handful of men there's
going to be a handful of men that like
fat women yeah so you still got a good
are Still's a handful it then I would
get I would be on board I get what
you're saying it's like it's still like
the women who are over eight who are
really like and what they want to do out
here even princess treatment women don't
like the men that give them princess
treatment I do women no women don't do
what women don't what woman doesn't like
to be treated like a princess my big
relationship I want my big like love I I
okay so
got Rel I have a question okay I have a
I have a I have a wait wait wait wait
have you ever have you ever felt like in
a relation ship that you did more for
someone than they did for you yeah okay
and how long were you with them I was
with them for a long time but however so
there's myal that's my point that's my
point is women right no you just said
you just said you have to choose if you
have to give one
headline so guys guys what I do is I
just look for patterns and Trends that's
what I do I just look at Society I
interview all these people I see
patterns it's not it's not black and
white I I've said so many times there's
exceptions to every rule but women like
the men that they do things for not the
men that do things for them so we're
taught by this societ no you don't we're
taught by you were with the guy for
years that you said you did more then
the women if I talk to you physically
and emotionally financially financially
he did more for her that's you cannot
tell me because like he would get Louis
Vuitton and his birthday or Gucci on his
birthday okay I'm I'm happy you got your
bag but but but typically it's it's the
men that you like the most are the ones
that you did the most for typically and
that's what we're told all this media
there's all this marketing there's all
this okay there's all this marketing
saying they have to do all this stuff
for us and it doesn't work women like
the men that they do the most for I'm
not saying they can't be nice to I think
it's the other way around I think if you
really like them you do stuff for them
is that person true for
you there's a harsh the harsh theity the
harsh reality of the dating Marketplace
is when guys are too nice to women women
reject them so I was talking to I was
talking to well it yes it does but I was
talking to Donovan sharp uh in Miami a
couple of weeks ago and he said on on
this podcast we were on he said he said
if you the best way to lose a girl in
Miami is to send her a good morning dear
text all right send her that good
morning darling text and she blocks she
blocks you okay and this is the point
because if you're too nice if you're too
much of a like an inity Comm Sim the
girl's like [__] this dude I want the
unavailable CH a good want the
unavailable CH
there if women really if women really if
women really liked this stuff then why
do we have sayings like nice guys
finished last because some of them do
some of do guys guys guys guys but this
is I've noticed I've I've noticed the
it's it's too black and white comes in
whenever I say something that makes look
bad no that no we just don't always
agree with you and that's
okay you but but you wouldn't it's
usually true and I'll tell you why I'll
tell you I'll tell you why it's usually
true when people say it's too black and
white because you would say you're wrong
if I wasn't true no I just said not the
status quo I would say yes maybe the
majority or statistics show that the
like there's a larger percentage however
there's still a smaller percentage that
think that and that's okay yeah and and
I know but how many times do I have to
say in this conversation yes there are
exception I've said it so many times I
know there are exceptions we're talk you
keep saying that my fat friend should
just get lose weight and give up on men
until she loses weight I don't agree
with that but also why can two things
true why can we have two things that are
true exactly two things can be
true both true I feel like only PE is
saying they're not she is to agree to
disagree friend doesn't have to go on a
diet to
get might her if you have a best friend
and she's quite large right she's not
even that big but if you have a best
friend I'm not specifically talking
about your best friend I'm just saying
if you have a best friend and this best
friend is quite large and you know that
statistically men like Slimmer women and
you know that she's a type of person
that she would do so well in love or a
relation paron but would you then
genuinely say to her no you're beautiful
what like being fat and everything else
no they have to accept you the way you
are just I didn't say I didn't say she
was beautiful being fat I said she was
beautiful which she is externally
internally but I'm Jamaican Jamaican men
love fat women I'm sorry j that's not my
reality can I say
something my standard of beauty can I
say something let's remove let's remove
men Jamaican let's remove men from
this yeah but you're not born in Jama B
excuse me excuse me excuse me hello
hello hello hello
H let's focus on the on the on the
people on the show please um let's
remove men from the equation yeah let's
let me ask a real question how many fat
old people have you seen walking around
loads of them no I'm talking about old
people like above 70 loads of old
people I said walking about I said
walking about are you say they all died
yes
that's stand either they all dead or
have they have some health ISS skinny
fat people
can I can I make my point either they
are all dead or they have some health
issues that have impacted their
lifestyle so they can't they can't live
a healthy happy lifestyle anymore they
either bed reading they have to be in
strollers they have to like they have to
have people help them about it's a
problem so when you keep making this oh
yeah but she's you're actually
contributing to the problem how fat do
you think she is
blood it's not about how fat it's not
about how fat she is the fact is that if
you're fat she not IM
yes she might not be now she might not
be now but there's a trajectory that it
goes through you don't just SK people
die young as well because they're too
skinny and they're not getting all the
nutrients they
need too skinny though you would
probably
say wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wrong wrong wrong wrong you keep
saying things that are just not true
women are SKS that don't get men wait
wait wait wa wa wait wait women are not
dying from anorexia it's rare it R come
on statistically what percent of okay
okay what percent of women do you think
are underweight Google it go on underwe
you us do your no one's underwe under
European
standards given these statistics what
it's less than 5% Mel you're obese is
not I I don't even know exactly am
clinically obese yeah we're all obese
according to European standards we are
obese imagine that ABS over my vital
organs but I'm clinically
obese my bad sorry
BMI I said as I said earlier there's
exceptions to every rule yes we know but
in general BMI works works for
identifying so are you a base no are you
overweight no are you sure not by not by
not by not by BMI no I'm like in the
like the normal section on a UK sizing
what what size do you wear I don't even
know I get my clothes from America
you're like I would say you're 12 to 14
and I would say 12 to 14 would be
considered fat
here but you're not not 12 to 14 is not
F why are we saying that that's not guys
guys guys guys on European standards
that would be considered I
disagree I don't really I don't really
care like it's like like it it's like
but you guys are missing the point
OB the whole the whole point is she
keeps trying to lie she this one's a
liar this one's a liar because even the
anorex you kept saying that like women
die of
anorex I didn't say anyone died of of
anorexia I said there are going to be
people that are elderly and have died
cuz they're too skinny cuz they're
malnourished that's what I said and I
didn't say cuz they're anorexic I never
use the term anorexia at all older
people die for a lot of reasons but he
did make a very good point which is you
don't see a lot of a lot of fat older
people walking around the streets you
just don't but also I have skinny
friends they're beden
and they have
have y I've been a support worker for a
number of years so I do see these
overweight elderly people they do exist
they're within their house are they
totally bedridden they just like they
have to get some are they need
assistance but they they're alive
they're still about and there are normal
there are normalized elderly people that
have the same situation they can't get
about they need assistance
but in general in general surely we
could agree that being Slimmer keeping
in shape is going to be better for your
overall health yes I agree for your
joint I agree but I don't think it makes
you it makes you less desirable because
you're fat cuz someone's going to like
it does make you
less wait wait we could have saved 45
minutes I'm going to read super chats
okay um shade W um honestly women keep
talking over each other tonight Dane um
my wife of 34 years is modern only in
that she works out of the home she's an
oil refinery mechanic earning six
figures but she calls it our money One
bank account cooked dinner makes my
plate boundless Guardian question for
the panel do you think the average man
has access to the top 20% of attractive
women I think most people can't date
outside of their socio economic status
or attractiveness or because they
haven't been around them danne uh
Schneider what what are women better at
or what are healthy women better at the
challenge is finding a healthy woman but
a healthy woman is so good for a man's
peace but I know she's the exception not
the rule boundless Guardian question for
the panel do you think the average woman
has access to the to I you did that
twice okay I I'll read that after I read
the rest okay danne Schneider Pearl I'm
Dane 54 father of six and I ain't even
Catholic I've been married 34 years my
wife is traditional except she works
outside the home um Dane Schneider Pearl
I'm using your content a modern woman I
know um she's a classic 34 year-old
single mom has her MBA she's a realator
and follows the Zodiac I'm a I'm Baptist
but pray for me Dan Schneider PE gy
gynocentrism is simply saying that the
culture revolves around women I see that
you are struggling to Define it it means
that they are the center I tweeted a sh
uh shirt at I I tweeted a shirt t-shirt
picture at you um I posted my wife in
her t-shirt on Facebook and two when
commenting asked where they could buy
one I'm buying one for each of them I'm
in Alabama and so many women here love
them Jam 90% of whales use filters and
angles to highlight their face that only
show their pictures on dating sites to
catfish men
um don't Gaslight these whales into
thinking they're attractive Doug MPA
lizo is 320 pounds 22 stone women say
lizo is pretty ladies if a man tells you
you look like lizo how do you feel J
yolum um OMG wait OMG these women need
to shut it off about the patriarchy the
world is built on the backs of men if
you don't like it go live in a cage Hunt
and Gather your food put um on leaves
for clothing Scott um M
maternity mandatory paternity testing
should be performed at Birth before the
birth certificate is a field without
ception um purple um Ginger something
women don't like to be perceived as
shallow they will never admit they like
it women don't like to be perceived as
shallow they will never admit that it's
a Tyrone or a Chad they're talking about
it's all about accountability they
didn't pick him because he was tall in
all the right places see um Blake when
you do of work or any other kind of sex
work you essentially give up your
reputation and morality make better
choices in your next life boo boo Jay um
says no one is is going to say
argumentative women really let's include
Hyena's laughter in there uh Let me
refresh it really quick yeah guys make
sure you get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt guys look at this women we
can't the women on the panel tonight
can't even admit that fatter women have
less options no offense guys should we
have the right to vote no no no no take
it away you've seen you've seen this
struggle session for 45 minute get your
T-shirt right now the link is in the
description the audacity network. store
that's the audacity network. store um my
honestly okay I read that okay so going
back to my PowerPoint my very nice one
here
so disqualified from being a housewife
only fans porn star overs spender
cheater um over 30 not being attentive
smelly selfish a liar not fat
argumentative um a
child um so o being a ho on social media
so I have a question would you give up
your social media presence to be a
housewife yes I'm going to go start here
and then go around and then tell me yes
why yes or why no I would say no because
I get a lot of work from my social media
presence and yeah that's but now you
don't have to work well but I like it I
enjoy work working okay I love my job
okay no go ahead no I would I would give
up my social media presence to become a
house what about you I would as well um
depending on the the value of what he's
compensating if it's going to be
bringing in more than what I'm earning
yeah 100% social media fact I would
easily you got to talk in your mic make
sure you're talking your mic I would so
easily compensate if it was um Can can
you
talk I would e
[Laughter]
softly gentle like a woman should okay
so you you would delete your Instagram
gone tomorrow it has to match the
energies have to match no he says I'm
going to marry you let's have kids mhm
mhm Instagram gone yeah and yours gone
you're an artist he he still has his you
don't have yours no for what reason way
does that change your
answer you're an artist you could you
put your phone away while you're on the
show please I I can um thank you um what
about you I would prefer to Rebrand but
if I had to completely shut off my
social media we're talking like oil
money like how much is your social media
worth now then uh it's more so about
like what I love to do I love put out
art I love creating um I'm going to need
to be able to put on some [__]
exhibitions and somebody else need to on
social media can I just say if there's
any sugar mummies watching this I'm 100%
ready to delete all of my social media
tonight um in exchange for a life of
luxury and doing nothing and King as
well I think I just want the piece of it
it would literally be for the piece yeah
I I I don't think deleting my social
media is like the worst thing I can do I
do think there's more outside of life
than having to like make money or or use
it but
yeah what about you guys for a sugar
mama would you do it I
would not even for a sugar mama like I'm
not in an Ideal World if you could just
get rid of social media I'm happy to
jump on board with that I'll jump on
that okay what about bank accounts so
would you give up your bank account for
a guy he handles 100% of the money you
make zero financial decisions for a
lifetime lifetime I've had a joint
account and I put all the money in it
and he helped spend it and would I do
that again no so I think in order for us
to have a joint bank account he he would
have to be the main bread winner and
he'd have to make yeah you're I said
you're a housewife oh oh he's making a
significantly larger you have you have
zero choice though you can't decide what
you buy you can't decide um what your
allowance is you don't get to decide
where your house is where you like every
financial decision you wouldn't do it
okay I have no control over any Mone no
control so I'm not allowed to any that
you
yeah you you h i mean you give them your
body you can't give them your
paycheck it's kind of backwards is it
yeah
like really I'm I'm it's not I'm not
thinking about oh I giving in my
paycheck it's just I'm literally
thinking okay but what when when [__]
hits the fan sorry then what happens you
trust
him and the first no you you trust him I
mean in this situation you're you're a
housewife okay if I'm a housewife and I
100% trust you then okay
okay what about
you
no she's honest she's these two are
honest go ahead um you said a lifetime
like what if I want to get divorced but
um so it's not I mean as long as we're
together nothing in your as long as
we're together do you know how much is
in my bank account now so the answer is
yes for me yeah you would you'd give up
your bank account for a lifetime yeah
okay a lifetime for whil I'm with that
but person yeah sure as long as it
doesn't extend past I decide I don't
want to be with that person I think I'll
be fine but yeah you get zerar if you
leave I have Z do now okay
amazing okay what about
you uh you said no
oh I'll contact my music
lawyer and discuss it formally no no
okay so was the question su Sugar Mama
would you give up your bank
account surely I'm in need of I don't
know
that's a weird one I've never thought
about that before well it used to
because there used to just be one bank
account and the guy got access to it
typically then I'm in control of the
expenses and all of that yeah yeah she's
in control of
the he doesn't even understand like well
kind of maybe
you what about you for your sugar mama
could you give her your paycheck yeah
sorry man I'll give her everything I
social media card account account
whatever
as long as there's an
out I don't know I don't know I even if
I had a sugar mommy I'd still want to
have make my own money like [__] that I
don't need to make my own money no I
think for me personally like the way I
am just set up like I need to have my
own yes she can have a lot of money you
want to travel somewhere private J that
but like I need to just be outside doing
something I think the RO were reverse
though I was just thinking if I was a
woman I would be the biggest H bag on
the planet do you know what I mean I'd
have only fans I'd be on the sugar
dating sites I'd be getting flown to the
buy I'd be doing all of this kind of
[__] do you know what I mean but what if
you was an ugly fat woman TR that means
is a low value woman no if you was an
ugly fat woman Troy what would you do
lose weight exactly be well if you
couldn't lose weight what if it was
impossible what if you had a not run a
business you're a woman i' build a tread
Bill I'd be doing you would not buil
anything you could utilize your fatness
cuz some men like fat women We've Ended
this conversation men don't like f Wom
if you was a if you was a female and you
had taken if you was a female and um you
had turned around and you said Okay I I
I'm going to be the biggest hob bag are
you willing to give up all of that give
up your social media and give up your
bank account for a man to come and take
over well if the I mean yeah I guess if
the guy was was if we now we're talking
about the opposite of what we just said
so if the guy was high value enough and
he was going to take care of everything
then yeah because it would be the same
answer as if it was a sugar buming right
yeah said cuz that's the ultimate price
that's the ultimate cash out isn't it
for the woman really it's to meet the
dude who's high value enough he's going
to take care of everything you don't
need to worry you just have an amazing
life we're just going to have problems
if the taste is not matching to be
honest that's that's the only thing it's
like okay yeah sure I'd give it up
hypothetically but like it's like oh you
have to wear this dress and you have to
go here it's like yeah yeah I have to
enjoy it okay so I my next question how
many children would you have to be a
housewife I always wanted to have two
children and adopt your
children no this is like birthing what
about would you do four out of my later
Garden yeah um what age am I starting at
this let's let's let's just say you
hypothetically could have four more kids
I would have four okay you would do it
how many kids would you have to be a
housewife are we allowed to
sah no you're not supposed to Outsource
motherhood what's the point of having a
housewife if you can't get kids out of
her really though like really not
there's no point allow is
I mean there's really no point for a guy
to get married if he's not getting kids
yeah but why do I have to have them
that's not my answer I'm just asking
like um it's not why I I think it's
weird to rent out a womb weird is not
it's not a good enough answer for me
have had oneid I think two I I think
that you need
your yeah when when you have one kid
then then comment no I I I can still I
could don't C I can answer the question
though I can answer the question though
is no you can't you haven't had a kid
out your B where's your womb where's
your where's your no I'm not talking I'm
can you can you relax where's your
vagina I can answer the question about
why I can answer the question about why
you wouldn't want to Outsource having a
kid it's because of DNA so oh no I'm in
surrogacy there's a way to have
everybody involved it's a way to have no
what I'm saying is you're having you're
literally adding an extra DNA into the
equation is that
fact
so a surrogate DNA is found in a child's
DNA I'll tell you why because is it bro
literally you're literally adding
someone else into the equation and there
is no way equation or the DNA yeah the
DNA is going to be tainted is not
tainted are you saying this
scientifically or from your own personal
view okay awesome you can Google it it's
true like
scientifically and the other to be
tainted and also men don't want to spend
like 30,000
she's nothing to him no no do you know
what's funny do you know what's funny
the funny thing is I know that you with
that mentality have not been by rich men
that that's what I know because I the
cheapest yet not not real ones I know
I'll tell you I'll tell you if you have
I I've had old pool boyfriends and I'm
taking care of you know and I'll tell
you why because because because wait
wait Jesus Christ so because the most
successful men that I know don't like to
waste money they're the cheapest men
like men that have money know how hard
it is to make money they don't like
spending it it's going to be different
men that we know isn't it because you
know we have different social setups
different social backgrounds we're
different races with different ages it's
going to be different you can't it's not
everything is not just black and white
can't
generalize she's right I've never dat a
rich man you a general opinion I'm I'm
the rich
man no I grew up around those families
so I'm
like I mean I'm not I'm not going to
list them families have been rich like
like like I grew up with nine I grew up
with nine siblings my dad owned a bit
I'm telling you like Rich the wealthy
the wealthy men and I'm not even talking
about entertainers actors those are a
different breed but like actual high
value wealthy men are not SP are not
dying they're not they're not dying to
spend 30k on a wife if it for from that
and so I'm saying surrogacy is not
typically what they
want um who all right so how many kids
would you
have
um two boy and a girl okay what about
you what was the full question it was
like if I to be a housewife to be a
housewife um I I don't have like a I
have a preference that I would want like
three maximum but I don't have like a I
would never like okay so if he said
seven no as a housewife mhm to be a
housewife is like yeah I know you're a
housewife okay I
mean
sure wait wasn't mean exctly me for me
like what I'm imagining being a
housewife like yeah sure I would have
seven kids that's a Bo that's a board
question isn't it what does that mean my
Grandma had nine kids why can't I have
seven kid well my my whole point is that
women want to be Housewives typically
I'm not saying you guys do but what does
house to you that you stay home with the
kids and and and have what else I'm just
making sure the kids get to College
alive and they're
smart what is what is a housewife to me
in 2023 or what has it been
historically yeah in general literally
genuine question so I I would say the
modern housewife adds very little value
um I would say no no no the modern I I'm
going to answer I'm going to wait I'm
I'm going to if you guys could listen
without erupting I I could get to that I
would say the modern W housewife has two
kids a lot of these housewife have have
nannies and really most women haven't
really been raised to be wives or taught
to be wives I would say I would say a
hundred years ago the average woman was
a housewife and was raised to be a
housewife the average woman had a
cookbook the average woman knew she was
supposed to serve and submit to her
husband the average woman had seven kids
um but
unfortunately um I I would say it's
typically gone and I think the kids are
the ones that are affected because now
you have all these mental issues
depression I mean even you guys were
talking about how you wish you had your
dad around um yeah and I think that most
women are not raised to be wives so I
think with that low expectancy didn't
answer the question didn't
answer answer the question I know I I
said a hundred years ago that was a real
housewife typically now in 2023 it's
still it's in 23 I I would say if you
going to be a housewife you should be
able to offer as many kids as he wants
you should be giving up control because
he's taking you in
um right now because she cannot cope
with all of this because it's going to
be too much going to be too much the
podcast you can't do all the podcast and
the and the children it's impossible oh
no yeah of course when you have kids you
have to give that up that's what I'm
saying because because of course
because kids are kids are kids are more
important than whatever you're doing
totally you're saying you're basically
not capable of actually being a
housewife yourself yeah am I not capable
of being a house I think being a
housewife podcast you say I would say
being a housewife is pretty easy but
you're not capable of having a good
business you're not capable do both
right currently right now one or the
other currently both together well it's
not capable it's not capable is it it's
about how she
how she would prioritize Woman as a
woman as a woman statistically what
she's going about of
Statistics you can't do both what's your
answer to the same question which which
which I don't even know what she's
asking it was uh how many kids would you
have to be a housewife right I think the
question more is about would you give up
your career for your husband you like is
that question yeah cuz she can't even do
a career cuz she's a woman anyway so
she's not it's not going to be
successful is it is that the question
that's not what I said I said most women
are most women can't do what I said um
the second thing I would say is yeah I
think once you have kids it's about the
kids it's not about you I I don't
believe in um I always just say I'll
have as many kids as I can you would so
that's your answer as many as you can
put on your mask before helping anyone
else mean I think I think I probably
would have had to start it earlier to
have seven but um he says I want you to
start now and anything else I got you I
got I got the money we can do this cut
off your cut off your podcast bye yeah
I'll see you sorry sorry sorry guys
you're you [__] no
more all the guys all the guys are like
no [__] you [__] you sorry guys sorry no
but but the whole point is and I've
actually kind of put things in place so
I can like step away when that happens
to be honest I I kind of have a plan for
it anyways why get in place though be
because because you want to have a
family like I I want to have a family
housewi then why you need put in
place your mic well I don't to be to be
to be fair I don't think most women
deserve to be Housewives I think deserve
I think like we're in this entitlement
culture where everyone thinks they need
princess treatment I don't think most
women have earned it I think typically
housewives are picked before they're 25
typically um their priority was um
typically they have a cookbook typically
you know they were raised to be wives
that was their
priority does every man deserve a
houseworth no and Men know that no
absolutely not but most men haven't
reproduced historically a big woman and
that's not the same format that we go by
it's just not what CH go ahead go ahead
times change huh not the format of what
where's your man where's your like your
husband what you're not going by that
format that you speak of the format that
you speak of it's It's guys are a nosy
Bunch
huh you're like tell me tell me your
family tell me your whole life but you
know you the same to them and no no she
wouldn't tell me I let her out of it no
because we we' we've all given small
snippet of all of our upbringing and
is as have I that's what I mean exactly
we all have so it's all small Snippets
and it just goes to show though it's
very very vast isn't it you can't
generalize no I think we can generalize
and I think we should go back to
generalizing I think it's okay it's okay
it's okay to as I've said I'm an average
chick I think it's okay to be average I
don't understand what's wrong with
saying the best women get married
all all the women left here aspire to be
wives right but not necessarily
Housewives is that correct cor all of us
here aspire to be wives but you guys
don't want to be all or just it depends
on everyone's perception of what the
housewi I'm asking here I don't know I
don't so you're not sure about whether
you would identify as a housewife what
is a housewife does that even mean
perception different
a housewi is someone that a
housewi a housewi isone that stays home
with the kids while the husband works
perception so in your perception that's
what it is traditionally that's what it
is no that is a housewife traditionally
I look up definition in the if actually
do it in the dictionary that's what it
is however it's
Antiquated everyone of the you're here
with your headphones on interviewing
people you definitely in a housewife
though well only 10% of women get it so
you're not the 10% but she's not saying
she to be a housewife she's not saying
she want to be you want to be a
house do want to be that's the big
question I when I when I have kids I'll
stay home with them same you know yeah
how can
you four years when my kid stay was in
school he was in he we I stayed at home
with him
Yes again when I do it don't worry this
the statistics are not correct you will
be a
housewife
so% you change your feelings you change
your per perceptive when you come across
it my child I had him okay I had him and
then I stayed at home with him for three
four five
years that's how it goes but you were
still working right yeah I've run a
nursery my house y so technically you
weren't a housewife you were like a
three years I was a house 100% right yep
but working no for the first three we
years so can I just say was that because
your circumstances changed and your your
your child's father wasn't around
because my heart felt like I needed to
do more for my
child but what I'm saying was you
financially been provided for in that
first three years 100% my baby got me
after the three years then what did he
stop providing for you never but you
needed something more in your life for
my fulfillment and yeah for my joy and
for for my son's Joy I felt yeah wait
just wait wait what did you just say oh
Joy yeah that's you projecting on your
child
stability stability for my son's future
wa wait wait wait so you were a
housewife yes and then you left for your
fulfillment no no no I stayed in my
housewife's I had I had the um role and
the um position to be just provided for
and to stay at home and look after to
the children but I chose not to be I I
had my own Nursery in my house MH which
makes sense for me mhm so I ran that and
and raised my child at the same
time
okay
um but you're are you with him now no
not now why cuz we didn't work
out just be honest what just say like it
was you didn't work out it was him it
was him it was him yeah it was him and
if even if it wasn't we didn't work out
it's fine he's still a great dad to my
child like he's amazing he's still a
provider he's amazing he was still a
step up he's amazing we still have a
very you should get you should go back
he sounds awesome sounds like a great
guy call him get him on the phone call
him she's going to do it listen you know
what don't do it I think po you'd be
amazing woman for
him hook the up thank you really do you
so you aspire to be a housewife do you
like chocolatey
goodness
no you have the question oh
dear that's a whole another
show that's a whole another show okay
I'm going to read super chats really
quick um please say there's a matter of
lot fat women in there come on there
will not
be will not pleas prove prove I Wrong
guys prove I wrong all right I mean you
can you can show me um please do it for
$100 thank you all right guys U make
sure you get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today you cannot watch the
show and tell me that women should get
the right to vote or really do much so
take it away the audacity network. store
that's the audacity network. store okay
Alonso this panel is hostile there are
truly triggered by reality and regret FS
Claire women deserve everything in Easy
Life equality when they want it and
preferential treatment at the same time
this is why women or this is why men are
fi are opting to find women in the
Middle East or quietly walk away from
society entirely it is that bad Dane um
Pearl you told Christine we dated
cousins in Alabama they have to at least
be fourth cousins or a father Arkansas
it's third to first cousins West
Virginia it's sisters we rednecks or
something else joking well I heard in
Alabama I'll tell you what I heard about
Alabama I heard there was this family
that inbred so much they turned blue so
that was like no I heard that was a real
thing that's why I said that because I'm
like I don't know what is going on in
Alabama DMO I'm sorry but I can't stand
the disrespect by these women great work
Pearl Wrangler these people boundless
Guardian when you come back to them
please read both questions one is about
women and one is about other men um Sha
Sha D honestly the women keep talking
over each other
tonight uh okay wait you said Dane
um I think let me see if I can find the
Super Chat you're talking about oh maybe
it wasn't Dane it was someone
else uh let me find it boundless
Guardian okay this is a super chat from
um boundless Guardian do you think that
the average woman woman has access to
the top 20% of male
earners no that's true probably probably
not no no no and I think they also asked
it from the men's point of view yeah but
no um and even less so for the men in
the other direction you guys think what
question again sorry do you think that
the average woman has access to the top
20 or do you think the average woman has
access to the top 20% of male earners
they can have like social media they can
have via
because a lot of women have access to a
lot of things it depends it depends it
depends what he means specifically by
average but I mean if we're looking at
looks because we've we've said before on
you know on this show if a guy is more
likely to to date a waitress or a woman
who works in McDonald's because she's
hot I mean a woman it's never going to
happen the other way around you know the
woman's not dating the dude who's
working in Publix or who's
working but the other way around it is
possible so um I think hotness comes
into it to a large extent if she's hot
she could probably get access to some of
these like celebrity parties celebrity
events stuff like that even if she's not
hot why you go smiling you're like
yeah okay and then second second part do
you think the average male has access to
the top 20% of attractive women no no no
way less so than the women yeah okay oh
attractive more more more of social
media these days isn't it
because no unless they pay for it and
only
fans not
genuine
um don't skip over the manat city LS fat
girls no
[Music]
no um I can't wait to hear more from you
Joseph thank you that's all of the super
chats all right um it's getting late so
why don't we do final thoughts and then
you can tell people where they can find
you on social media and then we'll close
out the show starting here in and then
go around and then second row you can
find me at Kelly k l o on Twitter
Instagram Tik Tok Facebook and I'm still
on mass Bas no really the only person in
the country is still on lot I think
people just use it for advertising space
to be
fair go
ahead what do you want final thoughts
any social media you want to
plug no none nothing she said don't add
me go ahead who what no okay so final
thoughts I think just to be more
understanding everything is not always
back and white everyone has different
setups and circumstances and so that can
contribute to different thought
processes this make it into the show but
you know everything's different isn't it
you can't just be black and white
anyways uh social networks for me Maria
French m r s h a f r n c h new n UA
joint
um social media official newer nuway
that is for me my sister we about group
I think
you um my final thoughts are I think it
is important to like be aware of like
factual and statistical information and
you should use that to make your own
decisions use that to like make yourself
I don't know just like have something
that you believe in and that makes sense
and that you're not just like blocking
out [__] that is real um and I think you
should go ahead and listen to my music
or H have jumbled thoughts and
alternative music you can find me on
social media and Spotify J kisses as J
Aja kisses everywhere um
yeah on
me all right thank you so much guys I
had a really fun time today so we're
going to catch um my sister and I on
official Nua and uh um yeah all
platforms all platforms it's very inform
with today so I really appreciated um
everyone's input so
yeah um thank you very
much it's really great being on the show
thank you very much PR King and um final
thoughts I think um from the topic of
today which is about Housewives and sort
of um um um single moms and Housewives
and that whole thread of about about put
potential of sort of finding a partner
and all of that I just think everyone
just needs to be a best be the best
version of themselves the women who a
single mom or without a child be the
best version of yourself a man who's out
there try to be the best version of
yourself go to the gym try to get a good
job just try and be the best version of
yourself uh my social media handles are
at least the one I'm going to share at
the moment is the real happy hour
podcast which is my podcast where I
reveiew film and TV shows if you'd like
to be on it please just send me a
message thank you very
much yeah thanks for having me on pear
great show as always uh final thoughts
yeah fat chicks it's just come on just
go on the tread maill just go on the
treadmill just do a bit of CrossFit you
know do a bit of training what if it's
Health go to B go down to I I'll go down
to baty park tomorrow with my training
we're going to do an hours worth of
boxing training do that just do some
stuff you know just lose because it's
going to it's it's it's going to widen
it's going to widen your appeal in the
dating Market that I mean I'm sure there
are some some dudes who like fat girls
but you're going to have a wider pull
if you lose a bit of weight so do that
and follow me on social media real try
Francis on all platforms and that's it
thank you all right guys uh make sure
you like the video on your way out
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
let's try to get to a, likes before you
leave also guys get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt at the audacity
network. store that's the audacity
network. store also we're signing
YouTubers here at the audacity Network
so um if you want us to put on a show
for you or something make sure you apply
um you can DM me at Instagram just
pearly things one also uh I think that's
pretty much it oh also subscribe to
Christine's Channel Christine Gray she's
our talent here like the video on your
way out and we'll talk to you next
time bye thank you
bye yay